the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the atmosphere is electric at the 2022
v-day candidates in beautiful madrid
spain players left it all on the boards
pushing to make a jump in the standings
before the first rest day of the event
chinese superstar ding lorin was primed
to do just that but missed two clear
wins letting a lucky richard rapport
escape with a draw carawana and
napomiacci are out front with the rest
of the pack close behind round four of
action-packed chess
coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everybody it is time for round
four of the 2022 candidates tournament
being held in madrid
spain
it is to determine the challenger to
magnus carlson and to bring you all of
the action i am grand master alejandro
ramirez here with my good friend
grandmaster yasir sarwan from our studio
in st louis alejandro as always a great
pleasure to be calling all the action
with eu and christian what a thrilling
tournament we've had yesterday so far
three rounds but it feels like we've had
a full tournament of stories already
isn't it hello everyone and welcome uh
to each and every one of you and thank
you for joining us for today's coverage
the event so far has really lived up to
its hype one most eagerly anticipated
events of the year has been brought as
nothing but hard fought games it's been
fantastic alejandra do the as the honors
of the standings absolutely we still
have two players at the top as both
fabiano corona and you have the formula
on the plus one two points out of three
on fifty percent you have young stuff
duda richard rapport ali reza furuja and
hikaru nakamura and well right now
all knight is one and not having a great
event temura jabo and chinese superstar
ding liran after three rounds what are
the winning percentages
that the players now enjoy alejandro
let's take a look at what happens after
round two we had these percentages and
of course we played round three where we
had four draws now you would think the
percentages stay the same they change
slightly actually remember that you're
playing people with the white pieces or
with the black pieces it also depends on
the rating of your opponent and
mathematically some of these players
have gained or lost percentage chances
even though every game was a draw so for
example alireza he's had three draws but
because he drew with white
against a lower rate of player round
three his chances his winning percentage
is slipped by one and a half percent
it's a tough tournament when you
consider hikaru nakamura to be alone
that was an incredible game exactly
one for the ages a 62 minute thing yeah
sir whoa
but what calculation can't even be
hearing that thinking too absolutely and
they have the time to do it because
let's take a look at our format it's a
very large tournament an eight player
double round robin that's 14 rounds of
chest and here's where they get all that
time to figure out their moves it's 120
minutes for the first 40. you get an
extra hour when you hit that mark and
when you hit move 60 guess what another
15 minutes and your 30 second increment
starts taking throughout the rest of the
game three time controls in fact no
draws before the 40th move can be made
no draw offers
half a million euro prize pool but our
schedule it's three rounds of the rest
day three rounds for the rest day and
we're starting our three in a row today
tuesday june 21st is round four we'll
have around tomorrow at one the rate the
day after and our next rest day will be
on friday and christian as always good
to see you my friend in studio what do
you have for us today
good morning yasser good morning
alejandro and good morning to every
chess fan around the world watching one
of the most exciting events of the year
the candidates the players are right now
recalibrated after the rest day and
ready to show who the boss is over the
chess board but let's take a look at how
they got to where they are at today and
we're going to start with the young
chinese superstar ding liran he
unfortunately started off with a
difficult painful loss against jan
nepomnyashi in the first round after
that he drew against duda and drew
against rapport in a much better
position unfortunately that one is going
to sting and let's take a look at what
happened with one team or rajabov going
into this event he drew against firuja
that's a promising start in round number
one unfortunately for him he followed it
up with a painful loss against hikaru
nakamura and he drew a couple of days
ago against jan nepomnyashi in an
uneventful game and let's take a look at
the american superstar the player with
millions of fans around the world that
is hikaru nakamura he started off with a
loss against his compatriot fabiano
caruana in round number one but
immediately bounced back with an
incredible grinding victory against team
raj above and then defended tenaciously
against first a very difficult drop but
he made it and right now he will have to
defend against rich rapport with the
black pieces
who by the way richie rapport coming
into this event a big touted player from
hungary he drew all of his games but all
of these games were very very tense
especially the first one he was on the
back foot against yan shishtav duda
could have easily lost that game also
against dingley ren one could say that
he was probably lost in that one but he
survived and right now he's re-energized
and will be trying to win with the white
pieces today and let's take a look at
one ali reza pierruja the youngest 2800
on the planet only 19 years of age he
drew in the first round against raj
above drew in the second one against
richie rapport and unfortunately for him
stellar opening preparation against
ikaru nakamura but he was unable to
bring the full point home and let's take
a look at what happened with jan
shishtav duda the polish superstar well
he drew in the first round against
richie rapport he should have won that
game he drew against ding and drew
easily with the black pieces against
fabiano caruana and let's take a look at
the former challenger for the world
championship crown jan nepognyashi he
started off blazing hot with a victory
against the top-rated player going into
this event dingley ren after that he
drew a difficult game with the white
pieces against fabiano caruana and drew
quite an easy game against timor rajabov
and we're going to finish it off with
the young american superstar that is
fabiano caruana we talked with him
maurice ashley he said his energy is
stellar going into this event he won
against his compatriot hikaru nakamura
in the first round drew against yane
pomnyashi from a better position with
the black pieces in the second round and
drew in the third round with the white
pieces again jans shishtav duda guys we
have an amazing event on our hands we
certainly do christian but i've peaked
ahead we have an amazing round of
pairings today don't we alejandra please
uh do the honors and lay the table for
round four it's difficult to imagine a
more exciting bunch of match-ups that we
have in the candidates in today's round
richard rapper with the white pieces
against hikaru nakamura hikaru actually
repeating the black pieces going from
the rest day that's going to be an
exciting one we know that richard is a
very very creative player yanni pognachi
against ali reza for ruja what a match
nepal with the white pieces he won
against his opponent in the last time
that they played classical chess we had
that in the grand chess tour in
bucharest where farouza went all out but
was unable not only not to defeat nepal
but never actually took that with the
black pieces yeah duda will be playing
against
and in another crucial game right
chinese superstar dingley wren with his
back against the wall early in this
tournament having lost in surprisingly
in round one will try to defeat fabiano
carolina leading players who is one of
the leading players to still remain in
the tournament and get back to 50
exactly what a clash that matchup is
going to be and of course all of this
fighting is for uh what are the players
fighting for they're playing for a half
a million euro prize pool which includes
a seven thousand dollar extra that they
get for every full point that they make
but of course this pales in comparison
for the top prize which is to face this
man grandmaster magnus carlsen world
champion magnus carlos in in the match
for all the marbles next year place to
be determined
absolutely we're looking forward to
seeing who's
and we've made our predictions as to
who's going to be the challenger but uh
well we'll see how it uh how it finishes
at the end you guys it's a big uh
face-off today yeah myself
and alejandro and what a game that was
uh last time they played against each
other actually dingley ran with the
white piece against fabiano carolina he
played the spoilers role against fabiano
in that one he played one of the best
games i've seen of that year
and play has begun and i just happen to
have the game of jan and alireza in
front of me
it's funny these days when people play
the open sicilian or at least threaten
like hey i'm going to play the open
sicilian and then they play d7 d6 it's
sort of like everybody and his brother
has been playing bishop d5 check here
and it's just like been avoiding
you know the very standard open sicilian
that comes after d4
and we've even seen queen takes d4
already once in this tournament c5 takes
d4 knight takes d4
guys
could we be
looking at a a an actual naidor we are
looking at an actual night or fight wow
as janiponic is not afraid to go into
the night of uh clearly alireza has
hinted that he wants to kill the
neighbor from these candidates he did
get the open sicilian against richer
rapport but robert took with the queen
that's what i meant changing the
character of the position but today
we're going straight into theory i'm
very curious on what team nepo has
prepared in these variations because
remember nepo is a night of player
himself exactly so entire books have
been written about one variation just
one variation
with bishop g5 i like to call the bishop
c4
the bobby fischer variation
the soviets dubbed it the sozen
variation and somehow that stuck which
makes no sense to me at all bishop c4
and then of course uh the english attack
with bishop e3 or with f3 bishop e3
knight g4 bishop
uh g5 another entire sub-variations and
incredible depth and the players have
now
gone into e75
and by the way the lifetime score
between these two uh it's not a lot of
games but it's already a lot of decisive
consideration yeah
three number one in bucharest i'm trying
to remember where farouja beat him i'll
actually have to ask christian on that
one and they have one draw so it's
pretty even steven between these two
players but not a lot of experience and
this is going to be our second open uh
the second night of the tournament which
is great just featured yesterday well
round three
uh between fabi as white and duda
i thought bobby got an advantage
out of the opening that led to an
advantage in the ending which he totally
misplayed in my opinion duda had an
advantage in that ending he didn't
really put too much pressure and for
those of you remember it was with knight
bd7 and b7 b5 and by the way
a very early h5 also well that changes
the character of the position right
because duda did play the variations
with h5 here uh nep was actually playing
the sorry alireza's playing the lines
with a quick bishop e7 uh
the move queen d2 comes on the board and
now playing h5 it exists but it's rather
rare okay uh main line is to castle and
go for the sharp variations knight bd7
has been seen as well but i think it's
considered to be an inaccuracy castle is
by far the main move in this position
and castle played okay and
should white
because black has not taken
the precautionary move h5 along
is it in white's interest to play the
move g4 this is a very instructive
moment as black actually has a
strategical thread in this position to
play the move d7 d65 and if you play the
move g4 here it looks like you might be
stopping me from doing so by playing d5
countering that with the move g5 kicking
out by knight but unfortunately this
doesn't actually work out for white as
the move d4 theoretically speaking is
already better for the black pieces wow
you get all of your breaks in and after
pawn takes bishop takes you recover your
piece because of the double attack you
don't actually lose material at all and
you solve more than solve your opening
problems in this variation you use it
past equality
very nice so in fact the move castles
does come with as you say the
strategical threat of advancing in the
center and therefore everybody plays
castles long we assume right yeah
it's kind of an automatic here and then
i'm guessing knight b d7 and g4 again
this is very very early part of theory i
mean we haven't even cracked into the
deep oh no we're not we're not even
starting
that's that's my feeling as well and
christian what do you have for us
well one game that it seems that we're
already out of theory is the game
between dingley wren and fabiano carona
check this out check what happened in
this one so they started off with the
typical rocko's and everybody plays
zaragoza nowadays at the elite level is
considered to be one of the most solid
defenses against d4 for a black no
surprise here bishop to b4 queen to a
four came quite uh quickly knight to c6
e3 of course white can go bishop to g5 y
can do a lot of things a3 is another
idea as well bishop to d to a lot a lot
of setups for both players e3 is
followed by castle queen to c to the
main line in uh the position and check
this move out knight to a5 came out of
nowhere for fabiano caruana it was
actually played only once against santos
ruiz miguel against blue bomb all the
way in 2019 only one game in the death
base in a position in which we have
hundreds if not thousands
of games but only one with knight wave
five this must have come as a shocker
for the young chinese player he
responded with c5 quite quickly he
hasn't spent a lot of time
five minutes right now b6 immediately
targeting the pawn on c5 look your
pieces on the queen side are quite
awkward the bishop on b4 most likely
once it gets targeted with a3 is going
to have to be exchanged on c3 the nikon
a5 we know the knights on the rim are a
theme in general nevertheless black has
a clear idea in mind and that is to put
as much pressure as soon as possible on
white spawn structure of course if we
get the exchange c takes b6 a takes b6
that is the dream for a black he's going
to be feeling uh very comfortable and uh
positively about his position in that
one because c5 is going to come after
maybe black even gets the advantage so
white needs to find a way to consolidate
his pawn structure on the queen side
right now and this is the big question
that he needs to answer
one of those lines in which white at
some point need needs to make some
aggressive decisions like for example
just sacrifice upon and play for
compensation we've seen that style of
preparation from fabiano caruana against
jan nepomnyashi as well with the black
pieces just play something offbeat take
a pawn and then trust the material and
this is exactly perhaps what we're going
to see in this one as well for example
the computer's main move right now is
actually bishop to d2 allowing me to
take on c5 nevertheless it does feel
like after take take if you do take
maybe knight to uh d5 is coming maybe
knight to a4 this is the type of
situation we will have to deal with
right now it's going to be a tremendous
game guys uh could i just ask the
obvious sorry to interrupt you alejandro
could i just ask the obvious question
and you've played c5 you played b6 i
want to go a3 yeah that makes a lot of
sense
a3 is is is definitely a move yes
take with the queen and now knight to e4
and drop back with the queen and then
let's take this all right we'll take
that right you take back you take back
yeah taking back already we've seen this
move queen to f6 from fabiano against
jan uh also queen to f6 and next i'm
going to play e5 how are you going to
develop your pieces obviously queen to
f6 is not only meant that supporting e5
but also stopping you from playing b4
the rook on a1 is kind of misplaced so
in fact the best move according to the
engine at least is rook to a2 okay i
wanted to suggest rook b1 or k2 go ahead
rook b1 i'm not sure if it's um as good
because you put yourself on this
diagonal
[Music]
yeah a b4 and then bishop f5 and then we
get the typical fabiano preparation yeah
right if we just conti because so much
of everything that you've done
to my eyes is so logical but it's going
to lead us somewhere so we're going to
go bishop d3 you're gonna go oh you're
not going knight c6 no no i'm not going
back nice i wanted you to go knight c6
so i could go comfortably bishop b2 the
knight c4 is very annoying exactly
that's why i keep the knight here so
that bishop b2 never counts on the board
well if it does come then you're just
going to lose the bishop air uh castle
and then some slow play bishop to g6 and
we have this type of position in which
it does seem like black has equalized so
i agreed i agree perhaps something else
from the beginning perhaps this idea and
by the way this is this was another idea
take take knight to e4 take and now the
move b4 sacrificing upon the type of
preparation that we discussed earlier on
and it seems like fabiano and his team
are drawn to this type of challenges uh
that they want to post their opponents
especially with the best that's a very
good problem that's a very nice pawn
soccer figure it is you take it you have
to go back to b7 that's an awkward
square but you know
that fabiano has probably analyzed the
ins and outs of this position right so
do you do that do you take that risk do
you sacrifice upon psychologically
could be quite difficult
marvelous stuff sorry and the lifetime
between these two uh players
it's three wins two losses and six draws
between these two players but i want to
point out that they have a very long
history of playing against each other
actually those three wins by dingleran
include a win 20 years ago they actually
played in the under 10 world youth chess
championship in iraqi greece right and
dinglerand won that match and i actually
know that because i was there
and i was there
i was like
i was there as well yeah yeah wow that
was a very talented group of junior
players where was it hell it was in iraq
and
island of greece i think fabiano was
like super uh highly uh rated and ding
was just an up and coming 2100 or
something long actually actually ding
was unrated i'm ready there you go
nobody he came out of nowhere he was
like 2 200 and then he shot all the way
to like 25 50. wow and then to like 2700
in in the span of a year and then the
rest is history
i have a theoretical question for you
christian and i'll bring it right up as
soon as i introduce it to our audience
i'm looking at the game between
richie and hikaru
and this very very topical
variation these days the berlin but with
d3 and bishop take c6
b takes c6 castles and now the immediate
bishop d6 there are alternatives of
course but
ikaro chose this move to defend the pawn
on e5
now richie said okay this is all very
nice and good i will develop my my my
bishop i'll pin the knight on a good day
i will follow it up with moves like
knight d2 and knight c4 and i'll really
start to target this e5 pawn
now usually at some point black tries to
make amends and somehow
you know i've seen him put his knight
back and play f7 f6 to re-fortify
uh the pawn on e5 but what icaru did was
rather for me surprising he just
immediately
kicked the bishop
right to the square where he could
attack the pawn on e5 and after the move
bishop e6 icarus just laid down the
challenge
you want my e5 pawn come and get it come
and get it take it just before we start
take a look at what's happening in the
other game and we were talking about
trends and the audience was asking us
about trends as well take a look at
what's happening in the shishtov duda
versus timo rajabov because i was
confused you told me hey hikaru played
this and i was like no no he carol
played bishop g5 before
it's actually a different game but with
the same idea this idea of pinning the
knight as early on as move number five
with the move bishop to g5 h6 bishop is
h4 now bishop takes c6 take and bishop
g5 could come and that would uh be a
transposition of the game richard versus
hikaru but right now it does seem like
black has an option an extra option
compared to what we have in the hikaru
game to play the move knight to e7 it
just all comes down to trends and it's
so interesting that we're seeing two
players that have absolutely no
connection with each other we know that
uh
didn't call richie rapport before again
and he was like hey what do you have
against the berlin yeah i have this
bishop g5 idea let's play it uh together
tomorrow that's not what happened but it
seems like their teams were drawn to the
challenges once again the tests that
this idea with bishop to g5 bishop to h4
is posing from a practical point of view
quite an interesting moment in the
canvas right now uh nice competition but
then
back to the hikaru game for just a
second
we have a very pressing question right
hikaru has said
i'm prepared i have you
white has just made no pretentious
whatsoever he's going to go after this
pawn
and you know hikaru is supposed to
defend the pawn he's supposed to play
queen e7
and or he's supposed to play bishop g4
to stop the guy from taking the pawn
some concession and instead icarus said
you want it it's yours is this
theoretically uh a known
position not 100 sure it does seem like
this bishop h4 g5 already might be a
novelty wow according uh to the database
that i'm seeing but perhaps this is not
an updated database g5 bishop to g3 and
our producers are telling us that
actually it's bishop e6 uh that is a
novelty and i will trust var our good
friend of ours
productions only presents sorry that was
tom tom was that was tom right
absolutely the producer yeah
but he's a great he's a great player you
know
bishop e6 and very quickly there wasn't
too much 65 is a move yes so much
discussion with the avalanche that's
coming your way
well there wasn't too much discussion
from richie's side after he saw them
with bishop e6
he rather quickly put queen d2 on the
board smell the rap
he smelled that kind of makes sense
right because if you play this move
bishop g5 you have to look at the only
game that's been played in this lineup
for the move g5 because we're being told
bishop e6 is a novel team uh the game
that i found uh is actually fabiano
caron against wesley so but it's from
one of these bazillion of blitz
tournaments that was played throughout
the 2021 year okay and that game went
queen e7 but which is a very standard
looking move to my eyes yeah you just
defend the player it was a rapid game
and after d4 black is technically in
trouble but okay rapid game online and
wesley ended up winning okay with the
black pieces but bishop e6 is actually
the top computer move apparently wow so
no surprise for either players richie
doesn't really spend that much time on
on anything and plays them with queen d2
which is not a very natural move in my
opinion
but in fact it's not even a pawn
sacrifice i'm looking at the lines and
it does seem like black is recapturing
the pawn quite quickly so for example
after knight takes e5 h5 now you're
forced to drop back with the knight
because h4 is coming you have to offer
this this bishop trade bishop takes g3
if you do take with the h pawn you're
just going to get slaughtered on the
king side after h4 don't open up the h
file because you're going to be in deep
deep trouble so what you have to do is
actually take with the f pawn but after
this i'm just recapturing my pawn uh by
force after g4 knight moves anywhere
queen to d4 comes that's a check you
have to move the king i'll pick up the
b2 pawn i'll uh get back my opponent it
does seem like this is quite okay
we have a question yeah i'm just
fascinated that
that's okay for black at the end
honestly but i'll believe you on that
one but we were wondering what happens
if you go h3
instead of giving the pawn back right
why do you drop back with the knight
right here i go h3 right right
are you are you sure you want to face
the music on this side
i'll suffer for a pawn all right so what
if i start with this
well
move
would we didn't consider why
would never cross my mind i mean i was
looking at age four right
you didn't you dirty rat he reaches for
his age
is what we're ready for
he looks up
quite bad right because if you do move
the knight and i still have this option
of taking on g3 you have to take ground
point and then this idea with queen uh
to g4 if you don't do that then my next
move is h4 followed by g4 and you're
going to get checkmated on uh this uh
file the g file uh it's just too much
compensation and when your opponent is
blitzing out yeah there are moves you're
not going to take on your fight you're
not i get that i guess i get that it
also it also does give me a feeling
quite honestly that richard is not
completely unfamiliar with the position
oh for sure he's he's not playing as
slowly as you would expect somebody that
possibly
surprised yeah right especially with the
move queen d2 the move queen d2 to me is
so unnatural that it must be some sort
of computer move because i i don't get
it it's so the idea is uh want to go
queen c3 i think exactly white wants to
go queen to c3 it's all about that
pressure on the e5 square and
he um saw that in the game between
fabiano and hikaru fabiano essayed
something very very similar this idea of
getting the queen to c3 and then putting
pressure um on c4 the knight coming back
to c4 and so on we've seen what happened
in that one and i think
this is somewhat natural maybe not
natural but known at the elite level
this idea of queen today to quintus
and we do have by the way queen to d2
and at last uh hikaru
does
make amends and says no you know i
actually really do like my guy on e5 he
defended it with the move knight d7
uh furthermore
uh further attacking the pawn on e5 with
a d3 d4 and now the fact that ricardo's
already got his bishop on e6 some kind
of a plus for black here in
the that his development has not been
um
made any more awkward
uh queen f6 and i don't know to my eyes
if i can get in castles
long that is to say i'm gonna be happy
i'll get eight i'll get g4 in
and away we go um has hikaru
achieved the beloved equality
it looks fine for black right after
especially after the move queen f6 this
looks
kind of okay how do we feel about all
these end games if i do trade everything
on e55 and then go queen c3 right
i remember uh bobby fischer queen of six
uh i'm going to spoil the party for you
guys f6 is actually pretty bad uh oh did
i blunder something i apologize no there
there's no immediate blunder but queen
f6 is going to be met by queen to a5
jeez
and i mean
karu playing queen h5 that's in one game
against timor
and now he goes queen a5
uh that's pretty funny okay we're only
looking at queen to c3 to put more
pressure on e5 but that allows taking on
d4 with a tempo on the right
the queen on a5 you still put the
pressure you still force the reaction
but after taking on d4 e5 just means a
piece gotcha gotcha wow nice
queen a5 pressuring e5 in case of
capture is just
what uh
yeah the queen a5 wasn't my mind
on my radar
it's such a good move right it really is
it looks like it just puts the which
means i may have to play the rather
awkward looking f6
yep and then take and take but he played
it he he played this type of structures
right sure
yeah i get it on this i don't like it
though i i just but to your question
even though queen f6 we now know
absolutely wholeheartedly is a uh
mistake right uh you did ask about this
ending and i remember
studying the games of bobby fischer
which we all did i mean we were all
spellbound
by his uh success and bobby
uh
won a few games of the exchange spanish
uh by doubling up the pawns but i think
it was because he was bobby not because
of the position
actually and i i gotta say that i think
that these positions are actually even
even okay yeah but uh if queen a5 right
we'll have none of that as a car has
played them with f6 which was the
computer recommendation and after take
you take with the pawn right right so
the idea is again if you leave black
uh alone
it's gonna play queenie seven castles
and i don't think
as white you want to allow
this
why
because you're facing some pretty
serious stuff right over here on there
so
whatever it is that white richie
in this case wants to do he wants to do
it while the king is still in the center
and he needs to hit the anvil hard uh
what's your take christian
that is a good question uh
yes sir um i'm not 100 sure i was
actually looking at this game uh while
you guys were oh please that's the one
between dingly ran and fabiano because
in fact
after c5 b6 we've seen a bishop to d2
happen on the board so no a3 uh no uh
immediate reaction from white's side
trying to target the bishop on b4 and
knight to c4 came on the board we were
discussing this idea of taking taking
and bishop takes c5 right this was what
we were looking at the problem is if you
do take on c5 it does seem like a3 is uh
giving white the initiative if you do
take on c3 then i just simply take back
then i will take back on c5 i have the
two bishops and the difference with the
previous line that we discussed earlier
on is that now the dark square bishop is
nicely placed uh and unbothered on the
square c3 you're not going to take that
bishop anytime soon and that's a problem
for black so
knight to c4 came on the board
and after a long thing almost 15 minutes
dingley ran plays this move a3 followed
immediately by knight takes d2 this is
the position current position that we
have on the board a lot of
simplifications are coming quickly
knight d2 bishop takes c3 is forced you
cannot go back because of b4 bishop
takes c3 is on the board right now these
moves are happening live as we speak
queen takes c3
let's see let's wait and see because i'm
100 sure that fabiano will blitz out his
next move a5 there you have it
there you have it a5 on the board
stopping this quick expansion with the
move b4 perhaps you don't want to do
that you're going to allow too many
trades that's going to simplify the
position too much
how do we assess this position i still
give white a slight advantage look there
nothing has happened uh the structure is
still intact for both sides i have more
space as white i like rook to c1 makes a
lot of sense trying to put some more
pressure on the c file finish the
development
i'm not risking a lot and this is
exactly what i think dingley wren was
looking for in that deep thing he was
looking for variations in which he's
going to be able to tame the position
neutralize black's opening preparation
as much as possible and i think
he got that i think he got that i think
he's happy and let's wait and see how
this game progresses
just to continue this exact moment b2b4
uh just i i've expanded with c5 let's
just
make sure the wedgie on the queen side
is maintained uh what what would happen
after b2b4 christian so in that position
that you had
this is the move
offered by oh wow
okay alien friends by the way that's a
real fabby move too just when you think
you've got that's another one yeah one
sacrifice like this
strange sacrifice i have to say but that
is a strange one
you will go after this e5 pawn and it
doesn't seem like white is going to be
able to defend it to a queen to d5 is
going to come quickly and you do have to
finish your development still i'm a bit
ahead in terms of development black that
is wow
so e5 could come on the board but let's
wait and see whether white is going to
decide to play b4 or not i don't think
it's a forced move by any means all
right that's great stuff by the way i
just i had a question for you alejandra
i thought that this was an actually a
very enterprising opportunity for ding
lehren right here he went in in my
opinion for the very natural move so no
complaint by what ding played knight
takes d2 i think everybody would play
knight takes d2 more or less and
transpose into the position that they
have on the board however
there was a strange moment here that he
could accept the doubled two sets of
double pawns on the f file as well as
the b file but at the end
he's really these double pawns
yeah you know control a lot of key
squares
and you know the worst thing that could
ever happen to black is something like
c6 b5 and you get this big clamp this
bishop ends up being stuck on on on c8
and i don't know what did you think it's
enterprising it's
strategically risky
i don't find it risky it seems kind of
nice for white actually you're never
worse in this kind of structures yeah
you have a double bonds but black can't
really make use of it and you have the
really nice g file you might also think
the king only one it's not so clear
where it goes but it's actually find
either on h1 even on e1 it's okay
i like this for white so much that i
would be thinking if there's an
alternative to knight takes f3 i would
probably take the bishop yasser just
because i think bishops are worth more
than ah of course this is
right here and just kind of
uh ruined the the king side castling
feature and i understand strategically i
have a little bit of risk if this bishop
on c8 doesn't come to life that's
exactly my point right i mean like
worst thing ever i'm just going to play
two incredibly bad moves apologies
everybody apologies apologies apologies
that you understand
yeah this bishop's not moving
that you are going to be actually
almost a bishop and a rook down for the
rest of the game you know because the
bishop is not moving i would think that
on those two moves though that black
should be able to somehow do something
for the bishop right whether it's bishop
d7 or it's something
uh get it to some diagonal where it's
actually actually breathing and your
king will be
one day yeah i was gonna play f for the
old castle but it will take some time
exactly i think i'll be able to use that
time to improve my own position as well
fair enough uh it just
it just
caught my eye as maybe a little bit more
enterprising than the very natural
pathway that
ding did take this looks very tame for
me i i actually
looking at this position i understand
what christian says i view it as being
completely fine for black yeah if you
had to compare and contrast this to the
uh queens can be declined with knight
bd7 that everybody's playing right it's
pretty similar except that white has
even less pieces than usual i think the
black is very close to solving their
issues now this is all great and fun but
we have such please fun game
in the alireza match let's do it they
have so much to talk about oh yeah so
much to talk about here let's go back a
few moves this is all theory guys um
everything here is theory
castles well let's say we just left left
here castle 77 g4 b5 g5
and this is one of the main lines of
this variation of the knight this is
some super old theory right it's not
yeah it's somewhat old and here after a5
f5
the old line and like automatic was a4
everybody plays a4 in this position
and it goes through like a very long
line a4 you take on east on on e6 knight
bd4 also exists yeah it's knight bd4 or
um
yeah knight bd4 or um f5 f5 takes e6 uh
a takes b3 is obviously forced then you
go
c takes b3 or e takes f7 they both exist
and it's just really really long tons of
games being played here uh literally
hundreds
literally hundreds of grand masters have
started from that position that's not
even the tabby's yeah
actually plays the move bishop c4 which
i looked at the database it's been
played 20 times and a bunch of them are
actually correspondence games no real no
real test in practice almost all those
games with knight g3 which seems to be
the computer move
yeah now knight g3 seems to be uh the
main line in that position knight to g3
king to b1
which was played one hour and 54 yeah
after a 10 minute thing so at this point
bishop to c4 seems to have been the move
that surprised you nepal miyashi he was
trying to remember his uh theory and
bishop to c4 was played but one thing
one trend that i want to talk about is
ali reza is surprising his opponents in
every single game
what he did he started off in round one
against timor he had an hour extra hour
on his clock
after that he followed up a ritchie
report richie was winning
at several junctures in that game
exactly and then in round three against
hikaru nakamura the same story and right
now once again we're seeing him just
blitzing out his moves all the way to
like move right now move 20 close to 20.
um stellar opening preparation i have to
say this young man has done his homework
going into his first candidates i'm
quite impressed homework or not the
position has blown up
it really certainly has what's going on
enough theory enough blah blah blah
let's take a look at what's actually
happening on the board because thank you
completely insane totally i mean black's
king is wide open uh black white
literally just decided not to take on d5
which is a free phone right and i mean i
mean what we're struggling yeah he takes
d5 i assume it's a typical knight of
type of uh sacrifice you put the knight
on d6 you start pressuring f5 it's not
easy to actually hold on to that pawn
and the knight on d6 is just so nice
it's so nice
it's it's chill i love that knight on on
d6 but
f6 but this is this is
okay
forgetting
um what will happen in this game
nepal loves the chaos of f6
i mean this is where he really shines he
calculates
uh the initiative
attacking variations in my view
incredibly well it's what
propelled him to become challenger of
the world to magnus carlson so when a
guy like nappa plays f7 f6 i start
sweating
but
i'll erase it
your worst
takes takes and now now there's a pause
so let's assume
this knight on d7 needs a job and this
knight on e8 stops mate yeah great and
it also could want to go to d6 more than
this knight on d7 wants to go anywhere
correct that was also my thinking as
well well and in the meanwhile uh do
your worst knight takes e4 is on black's
agenda
never mind one day some
ways of trying to blast open the queen
side with i would think that in this
position knight g3 is an automatic that
would be okay you want to go to f5 i i
know that throwing in a check on g1
seems tempting but maybe my king's
better on h8 yeah so i'll even i'll even
go so far as to say
yeah i'll i'll get off the open g file
i'll be happy to do so and i wasn't
really looking at the move bishop h6
it's one of those moves that you feel is
just completely wrong
i don't really care about just recording
fate i like the movie knight g3 i don't
think you're playing king [ __ ] against
it uh you don't why
i i mean to me that's kind of a natural
move where i want to go
rook g8 and
first you know i i i consolidate my king
side oh by the way bishop on c4s yeah
but i was thinking that bishop c4
followed by something like knight f5
might be scaring you not immediately but
a queen summer night only because i just
suddenly woke up
because it was like the bishop was on c4
and nobody had touched it for so long i
didn't even realize you i had given you
this opportunity well well well uh but
now having said that again at this exact
moment
black is a pawn up and he
has his chances as well right yeah it's
double it's not easy to check me the
black king with the knight on e8 it does
cover g7 so i don't have a checkmate
thread anytime soon let's invite
christian in here uh after the move
knight on d7 takes f6 which has not yet
been played
by ali raza
how do the
engines um
evaluate the situation well that's why
they pay you the big bucks guys
you guys follow the main line of the
engine all right to f6 knight to g3 king
to h8 great move getting off the g file
bishop takes c4 d takes c4 and of course
the engines are saying zero zero
zero zero zero zero all the way in
apparently this end game which is quite
strange i have to say but at this point
it does seem like your pieces despite
the fact that you're a pawn up are a bit
awkward right
you are ready to take on e4 what how do
you save it you just play bishop d6
knight takes e4 is coming as well for
example if you try to do something
[Laughter]
uh continue please uh christian uh zero
zero zero zero zeros and now you
sacrifice the second pawn with knight to
e2 and i guess you want to actually just
exchange the knights like this oh come
on get out of here somewhere out of here
wild stuff wild
good friend shakarev
to be honest at this point if we do get
into this position i don't see queen
takes the eight combo on the board i
mean it's actually i think you just see
some queen g2
f2 trying to keep the queens on the
board and checkmate
right the knight comes to f5 exactly
that's what feels natural to me i'm
sorry to be the party pooper that by the
way
is completely lost for white i'm up
i quit
completely lost i was going to suggest
you take twice on d8 in that position
bishop c5 and just kind of win back your
pawn and make the decision
yeah
so i go h5 you still have some problems
with this e4 pawn uh h5 is a very five
is annoying yeah yeah yeah this might
the other variation i didn't understand
at all but this one actually is a little
off-putting if you see the move h5 then
you realize that you cannot hold on to
it i mean i of course had the dream you
try to hold on to the point the problem
is that's bishop to b6 no no
once you start seeing rookie one you
think yeah this is going wrong i
understand this one yeah and and by the
way we have fascinating uh knight g3 on
the board alireza did take as we
expected with the knight d takes f6 and
knight g3 quick question for you
christian because of course we're gonna
have to move on but was uh knight df6
better than knight e takes f6 because
i understand that it's more logical to
take with the d9
but on some cases i also see that zeros
zeros everywhere
knight
ef600 knight df600 so
it's just uh yeah they were equitable
equitable uh sides of the coin i guess
yeah yeah but just completely different
variation i
i was waiting for that this is exactly
why you don't play this right
on g7 from a practical perspective
exactly with the knight on e8 you have
the control over g7 and it just feels
like your uh king is more secure
so that's why i think he spent a little
bit of time took on f6 with the d-pawn
oh with the d-knight and let's see how
the players are going to continue after
this one king2h8 does seem to be quite
an important move getting this king off
the g file you don't actually have a lot
of other moves to improve the position
well
i thought knight d6 was extremely
logical knight to d6
yes and bishop to h6 and again i don't
really care because you want to go king
h8 and say
take my uh
take my obviously you cannot go rook to
eight because of that yeah
i got made i mean g5 is made so i have
to move there is a mating threat you
also don't have time to take on e4
despite the fact that you control g5 you
do allow queens i i didn't see why not i
don't get it
knight f6 e4 sorry
knight takes you through queen g2 bishop
g5 counter check oh better there's no
check
this is a night good morning
good morning
how does the night on c1 what did you do
last night
all right
you need some uh greek yogurt over here
but guys just uh before i i'm sure we're
going to spend a lot of time analyzing
this position i just want to ask you a
question because
uh i was watching at uh this position
between richie and hikaru and they got
all the way to this position now
happened fast when i was seven years old
um i was playing the exchange rui lopez
and every time i managed to exchange as
many pieces and get to this type of
structure with only the knights on the
board i i probably won ninety percent of
the games
because i just as white right i just
exchange everything and then i push the
pawns i create um an extra pawn on on
the king's side the past pawn and then i
just win
isn't
isn't that the case
anymore is something changed in interest
is the defense for black much easier
than than i knew it to be uh obviously
hikaru is not my opponent when i was
young
chest changed a lot since you were seven
i know i know it doesn't seem like it
yeah
this was actually i think particularly
one of the things that did change about
chess i was taught exactly the same you
get to the exchange for lopez and then
you trade all the pieces and then
because you win the king upon it
the problem was that at some point
people realized that that last rook
you actually can't force a trade of that
last row four rooks off the board though
maybe two maybe but
the black will keep one black will keep
one rook and then you realize that okay
you're not gonna do anything the rest of
the game your only open file is the d
file and you put it on d6 that's what
you mean right you don't exchange it
because you put the rook on these six
the last that's one thing but even if i
don't have to like in a terrible
scenario i trade one pair of knights
okay so let's
let's go through the variations well
there's nobody's very
exchange everybody in a comfortable way
let's let's do it like this
you trade this i understand you can take
on c right we're not talking about that
even this you take take and you got
everything i gave you everything this is
a bit dangerous for black
but even this was like not lost i was
thought it was lost right yeah the same
here now they
and and then and then and then came
kramnik and then came to berlin now if
you put this rook on which is currently
on h8 on a8
people were playing a5 a4 you play a5
anyway and then you put your rook and
then suddenly this majority on the queen
side ended up
giving black play and this rook on d1
it's very pretty and stuff but it has no
penetration square because of the king
beautiful king on e7 or e6 so if you
just go in the position that you have on
your board just a few more moves
h3 for white if you don't mind yes a5
for black if you don't mind king e3
a4 for black a3 for white
rook yes all the way oops
almost got there and something like f4
and something like rook a5
and this is where we said
you just don't win four it's comfortably
bobby fischer yeah yeah i think it seems
like yeah people figured out that this
is a defensible end game yeah i think so
this is what changed in the past yeah
something here
this engine definitely changed people
thought okay white presses and
black figured out not at all this is
what we have right now on the board you
guys are saying it's an easy draw i'm
sorry is still going to try
the crazy part about this is i would say
that the draw is the overwhelming result
but i would say that three results are
still possible that even sometimes you
get into the four rooks come off the
board but the knight
for some reason black has a pawn on a4
and then suddenly he hits a pawn on the
queen side and it's not so comfortable
it's not so comfortable and the king on
g1 is actually pretty far from the
action it takes you a few times it takes
a few times together the night hops are
pretty quick yeah and yeah from my
experience of playing the same games i
never felt that
white was completely safe when it came
to pushing the engine the moment you
started pushing black had his own
counter chances by the way i'll
interrupt our train of thought for just
a moment to say that as we start this
the round four
we have in our three marquee games
fascinating openings great strategic
fights and we wanted to just invite our
audience to join the conversation as you
can send your questions to us through
the social media so welcome welcome
welcome and then one game we haven't
looked at
there we go send us our your questions
tweet at
santa lewis chess club stl chess club or
ask your questions in the live chat we
are on twitter we're on facebook we're
on twitch we're on youtube apparently
we're also on instagram so well done
well done
send me the questions wherever you they
really help the program they really help
our conversation and
go ahead and i just wanted to say even
though for
timor
timor is
having a very awkward uh start to the
event for duda
hey look you know the best time to kick
a man is when he's down and dude with
the white pieces if he could win today
uh the rest of you guys draw your games
and i'll tie for first let's just see
what has happened in this game and guess
what once again it's this
very topical stuff this time with d7 d6
so there's no bishop takes c6
bishop takes c6 d takes c6
trades
and
a very different
animal
i want to say i've seen a lot of joko
pianos
but
with the knight on a4 already
getting ready to capture the bishop on
b6 i don't know if we're still in theory
but
a big fight i've never seen this
position specifically it feels
it almost feels like something went
wrong for black right yeah it does have
a certain like i've seen black play a7
a5 a7 a6 always always always to
maintain this bishop right and and not
to allow it to be traded also
the fact that this
i mean g7 g5
uh in these positions now with the
bishop already uh sorry
uh stuck over here on the queen side i
don't think you want to castle long as
black
and you definitely don't want to castle
short um could i ask a christian
is this position that dude has achieved
as he
achieved theoretical advantage or is it
no he achieved a pretty decent advantage
i have to uh say um at least the way i
look at the position right now
the big problem it does feel like this
move bishop to b for created for a black
because you're just inviting white to
gain more space on the queen side the
much more natural bishop to b6 because
you're still gonna get there the
question is whether uh it improves your
case the fact that you allow me to play
c3 and b4 and it doesn't improve your
case at all because with the pawn on c3
and the pawn on b4 not only that i have
more space on this side but i'm also
ready to break in the center as fast as
possible with a move d4 so that might be
a problem by the way knight to a4 it
does seem like this was the novelty of
the game and um
timor did spend around six minutes at
this
juncture in the game and chose to force
or at least provoke this move c3 and b4
but yes unfortunately this doesn't help
his case at all this is what we have
right now it's an awkward position for
black i have to say i'm looking at the
options castle is not really a good one
and by the way duda look at him one and
a
half
points only half a point behind the
leaders he could definitely help his
case if uh he takes the full point home
in this important matchup against timora
equally true also the richie versus
hikaru game those two players are also
only half a point trailing our leaders
by half a point so a victory in either
of their cases would really help their
chance how can knight eight
come on
how can the move knight a4 be a novelty
i mean it's such a a a suggestive move
this bishop on c5 is a good piece let me
get rid of it it feels like it's one of
those novelties that's just novelty and
name yeah that honestly black shouldn't
get into this right right everything
that i've been taught about these
structures is keep this bishop alive and
actually you play a6 in order that the
bishop will have a way of retreating one
day right uh so bishop d7 invading
knight a4 and timur has got himself into
a little bit of a jam here it doesn't
even feel like i played b g5 because i
feel that c3b4 really
bothered
what i kind of wanted to play no it
helps
c3
i'm 100 sure that that's a tempo i'd
love to have in my right thank you so
much for the check on b4 thank you for
giving gifting me the move c3 b2 b4 okay
i can argue yeah you suck me into making
a move that maybe i didn't want but i've
seen
plenty of variations where
uh they do play d4 with the on on b4 so
i think dude is looking good looking
good and we have a question that i
wanted to ask this we've gone through
all the games already please
to the commentators did you expect the
candidates to open this fiercely or did
you expect players to test each other in
more calm waters starting the tournament
because it does feel that some players
have gone guns blazing with their prep
farouza has i feel that favi has in his
game against nepo where they are very
willing to take early chances i think
it's a wonderful question thank you so
much for that
because first of all i love the term
fiercely yes and i think that's a great
way of describing what's happened in the
first three rounds the guys have come
out guns blazing
none of this let's pace ourselves you
know and you know
introduce our novelties later in the
event no no no everybody said look i
want to get a lead in this tournament
and i want to play as hard as i can as
early as i can
for me
strangely enough i expected that i
really did expect
the hard-fought games that we've been
seeing
and but also i expected that they were
going to show
early and we've seen dingler in not
necessarily successful but um doing some
nice opening stuff and you know showing
his cards ali reza showing his cards not
saving that for the second half or
something like that
by comparison i think a lot of
um the
older candidates tournaments often
featured veterans who
who actually did save a lot of their
stuff for the second half right we do
have three
rookies in the field yes right and
they're anxious to show that i belong
and you know i'm gonna beat everybody up
kind of thing so yeah i think the the
combination
of maybe a little inexperience but also
with this uh aggression
you know has really hit everybody and
sometimes you pick up on that right
right sometimes you can have a
tournament where everybody's making your
draws and it's boring it's kind of the
atmosphere right right something in the
air yeah really affects the mood of the
sucks everybody is and then the next
thing you know they're playing you know
swinging for the fences so absolutely
yes it's it
it's been a surprise but a kind of a
welcome one definitely the the
atmosphere uh you're in uh madrid you
feel all the boiling blood the latin
boiling blood around you but also if you
analyze players uh by their own merits
you see ali raza furuza hasn't played a
lot in the last eight or so months he
only played in bucharest from what i
remember and uh
he obviously and norway as well and he
obviously prepared something for a very
long time and you were saying that he's
showing his uh guns early on no i just
think he has a lot of guns right now he
has a lot of preparation uh for every
single game so we're going to see new
and interesting ideas every single game
he's not using them just at the
beginning
of the tournament that's one player that
i have in mind hikaru nakamura also is
coming with a lot of energy richie
rapport for example he's been playing a
lot but always he has enterprising ideas
and that's going to lead to very
intriguing and creative games and
fabiano caruana nothing to talk about
him we know how good his preparation is
he just simply works non-stop on a chest
and always finds a new idea as the same
for dingli ren who hasn't been playing a
lot so if you look at the mixture of
players i think you can easily expect
that we're going to see fireworks in
this event
thank you christian i'm i'm looking
again at our number one seed uh going
into the event then larry against bobby
yeah the moment you look at the pairings
you go ah that's a game that you're
going to have to look at and i'm
forcibly reminded of um
a story that uh grandmaster robert byrne
told me robert byrne was a columnist for
the new york times and he
literally accompanied fisher on his
whole candidate cycle and he went goes
down to buenos aires in 1971 when uh
bobby is playing the finals candidates
against tiguan and petrosian
and this or the soviets sent an enormous
delegation and there was like robert the
only american and there was like tons of
uh soviet journalists tons of coaches
and trainers for uh diegrim petrossian
and ethan geller at a certain moment
just stopped and looked at the screen
and he said about bobby's play he plays
so simply
and i'm looking at this game of dingler
in and after the move a7 a5 rook to c1
bishop a6 captures opens up the c file
of which we are now the proud possessor
we have
our major pieces
uh controlling the only open file the c
file takes takes castles
and even though the position is very
very simplified
it's actually the onus that's on black
distill to show equality
uh very very quickly white would love to
establish his queen on a
c7 as rook on c6 his rook on c1 and then
it's just positional overkill so even
though nothing untoward has necessarily
happened
at the moment i feel that
dane through very very simple play has
put some um pertinent questions before
fabi how do you intend to equalize your
thoughts uh alejandro
i feel it's one of those positions that
very similar to the reload pest that
richard potentially has against sorry
has against hikaru that the evaluation
of this end games have really shifted in
the last 20 years yeah from being
somewhat dangerous to
boring to kind of boring where
grandmasters have taken the time to to
understand that even though this
position is not fully pleasant that they
do the extra work to take it from fully
not fully pleasant to just a draw and
wow that's impressive and i think that
this is one of them i i think there's uh
similar situations in the catalan
structures where off anderson won a ton
of games right in a position where
because he won so many games uh it was
assumed that white was better
but it was all for anderson
it was so fantastic and it wasn't that
the position was better right then
wesley took those positions with the
block he said hey look this is a draw
draw draw draw draw a draw never was
beaten right um and i think fabio is
going through some of the same motions
in this position okay where he
understands that he's definitely never
going to be better but is he actually
worse and if you make a couple of moves
for black please i would start with the
move uh
okay my first is saying 98 which is like
a silly move it it it makes something
resembles that remark by the way
but i was i was starting with the rook
a8 which i think rook a8
exactly okay so the idea behind rook a8
is as clear as a bell you want to be
able to challenge the d
for the d file the c file so i have to
uh step up right and here i was thinking
of the move queen b8 which is the i
think kind of typical
way of trying to solve your issue i try
to and i think by this point even though
it's only been two moves i am very close
to solving my issues help me just one
more move and i'll i'll be with you a
hundred percent
uh yes i'm going to take the pawn edge
if you play rook c8
but that's okay right i think this is
the kind of stuff like you go rook c8
you take my pawn but then i get my
counter play i go queen c2
okay
you have to play knight f3 yes yes yes
you want to get into this position why
don't we go queen d7 first
instead of queen v8 well alejandro's
point is that okay i've lost a pawn but
look what i've got in return i have to
play knight f3
you will probably play eight four it's
okay
maybe knight e4 just control your rook
is not going anywhere no i'm gonna be
tethered yeah to the f2 pawn i mean i
can see that this is counter play pardon
me christian you're saying that black
has an even easier option than this well
no i was just thinking not to give up a
pawn with queen to d7 r instead of queen
to b8
queen two he's like this
i go to b8 and i pick up the b2 pawn out
queen c6 go ahead and he's saying queen
d7 immediately right and that way no now
now you don't take a partner exactly now
i don't you can still take on d7 and
invade on c7 and i guess that is the
question how big of an advantage if and
okay but but that's the point i i mean i
still feel that yeah this is the type of
position i didn't want to get into the
white is the one who's pressing yeah
he's he's got the it's got the file yeah
i mean i think it's worth something i
think everybody's seeing the game bot
venice
and they think okay c file for the rook
knights dominated you know you start
getting uh you start remembering that
game and you think
i could lose like
right without with a whimper so perhaps
this is why the move that the producers
are telling us knight to e8 this might
tom is uh doing a little uh jig in the
background over here everybody
as thomas whispering in my 98
don't praise him too much he said 98
zeus one yeah
how crazy too much
uh
wow uh 98 yeah that was the first move
that came to my mind too
what 98 okay but my my question for you
guys is okay you're fabiano quran and
you probably looked at
this particular type of structure in
preparation for this game because it's
an easy path for white to try to get
very easy do you know this plan with
knight to e89 to d6 you probably should
right if you've done your homework you
probably should know the plan 98. you
can expect that this knight i mean it is
known in this structure right the knight
on d6 it really is an ideal square
because you get to support b5 and you
aspire to
shut the night this
sea file down just have a very very
quick well first of all let's take a
social media question but i got this
great story you have to remind me bobby
g oh okay let's take a look at our
question first it is
drumroll
who do we have montana don't leave us
hanging uh from youtube music patrick
hello hi pat how is the bonus money for
a full point awarded to the players is
it a bonus for winning games or just a
payout based on final tournaments
or it from what i understand it's a
final tournament score that's what i
understand it as well and even though we
did say 7500 i actually think it's a
half point 37.50
37.50 for a half point half point and we
just rounded it up and said 7 500 for a
full point sounds good sounds good but
yes uh so they have their prize money uh
first second third
and so forth but also um
a little bonus for uh getting that extra
point and and
another one
uh if you could try from lala
silver i think super gladly if you could
choose to be a second for any of the
candidates
whose team would you like to be on and
why
oh that's a good one
wow
wow that's a very good one all right i'd
like to be on richie's team
so i could just hang out with luber
mirror and talk about old times
i wouldn't want to do any work but
that's the why i would want to be on his
team
i just wouldn't want to do any of the
work that the trainers have to make uh i
know you'd switch after after years of
experience with bobby it's kind of like
i need somebody else i would die anybody
literally anybody else no i mean working
with bobby's a pleasure but i've already
done that so i would have to choose
someone else let me think i got a
dinglaran thing or doodah perugia i
think it has to be furuja
perugia would be fine i think it would
happen i suspect that might be a lot of
work christian jump in i'm okay
[Laughter]
i had a lot of fun with fabiano and
probably i would rejoin uh his team in
that regard but alireza is definitely a
prospect that i would like to work with
right um not only from the chess
perspective but i have a feeling he has
a lot of energy
in other aspects as well i think he
plays a lot of sports and this is what i
like in this type of camps i like uh to
play a lot of sports i know magnus loves
to play all the time so
if the player plays sports outside of
just preparation i'm gonna be on their
team let me get this straight you're
going as a second to chat with the other
seconds that guys take a second to do a
bunch of sports oh thank you guys
what a great creative player i want to
see how the new generation thinks about
chad i want to know about the new ways
of prepare you're great you're you're a
great chess purist i i i love you for
that
just a quick a quick story i thought
this was actually pretty hilarious so
i'm playing in beale in my interzonal
and a lot of friends come over from
seattle of a dear friend uh
bobby garcia bobby g
and bobby g
uh is you know protecting me from all
the swiss riff-raff
and i'm having a uh
um post boredom with uh the grand master
from
holland
john vanderbilt oh yes john's attacking
me like crazy like crazy and
i have a defense to his checkmate on g7
and i say i have 98
98 oh john says that's right that's
right
so a few moves later another variation
and once again my saving move is 98.
wow that's great says john v that this
knight is you know the bane and this
goes on actually for a few minutes and
then we agree that the game was drawn
and that away goes
and bobby turns to me and he says yes i
i'm really sorry i didn't want to
disturb you guys but what's 98
so 98 you go yeah i said well it's one
less than 99
because he thought we were saying the
number 98. instead of knight
to
e8
just
this hilarious moment of like what's 98
in chess because he kept
i mean i kept using it as a trump you
can't checkmate me because i have 98.
it was great
[Laughter]
let us take a look
what do we have for you from q boutique
oh yes what is our specials for today uh
our special for today is one of a kind
walnut and maple chessboard played on
autographed by gm fabiano carrana there
in the middle this was used at the
american cup and you can buy this
available only at cubitiquestl.com
look at that beautiful signature it's
horrifying
i need to learn how to write what is
that on earth
bobby gary wanna come out of that i mean
come on come on yeah well but it is
poppies we swear yeah that's an original
and you can buy it at qbt.com visit us
there we have a bunch of chess
merchandise for you guys we're going to
take our first break of the day as we
have finished the opening phase we'll be
right back in only a few minutes to
cover the rest of the action of the
fourth round of the candidates
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the u.s
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back we are in
round number four in madrid spain as we
are the candidates tournament for you
and this is the standings after three
rounds of chess
fabiano caron and yanni pognachi are the
ones that sit pretty top with two out of
three and a bunch of people on fifty
percent meanwhile team rajab of ending
le ren are the ones that have suffering
and determined currently both of them
sitting on minus one when you think
about today's pairings and how they
affect those standings my goodness what
pairings they are as we see in clashes
between
jan one of our leaders uh versus alibiza
farouza at one and a half only half a
point behind
as well as ding loren fabikan
versus fabi uh dingler in our
pre-tournament favorite is at -1 with a
win today
a lot of
a lot of the uh badness goes away you
know
eb would bring fabi back down to 50
bring himself up to 50
and make the tournament wide open so big
big encounters yeah big encounters
everywhere i i think the most exciting
one by far uh from the positions that we
have is the yonder pomnyacci game i
guess all the reservation we have a
couple of moves let's jump in we can
jump straight into it it's also a huge
one for the standings salareza trailing
only by half point uh behind current
leader jan nepo well we left it we saw
the move d5 and we used f6 and we got to
these captures we anticipated knight g3
and then there was some uh discussion
here whether we play king h8 well in
fact uh
ali raza captured on f1 captured and
ever since has been tanking which is a
bit surprising because what do you
expect
look at all of these things that
happened before and uh for sure for ruja
had brought
the
preparation up too and including this
moment only he's taken
almost an hour
uh to get here versus the 30 minutes uh
for yan uh
discuss uh what happened uh it feels
that he's unfamiliar with the position
itself
and he's trying to figure out exactly
how to move forward he must have some
sort of a certain idea of how the
position is handled but not on a
specific idea of the move orders okay
i'm a little surprised that after bishop
takes f1 he's still thinking because to
me taking with the h rook is an
automatic now you might think why not
take with the d rook keep the uh open uh
option open to put the h rook on the g
file it seems very natural to do so but
experience in the night or tells me that
actually the it's not about uh which row
goes to g1 is the fact that the rook is
actually better placed on d1 than on f1
okay and that even though on the file
that's half open
uh it actually doesn't do very much
because there's the pressure on the d
pawn and the tactics with the rook on d1
against the queen on d8 which makes it
better on d1 than it is on f1 yeah i can
see that right away as well like for
example if you take let's say let's say
i'm very callous yeah i go about my
business in a very brutal manner
knight takes knight takes pawn takes you
can go queen g2
and when you go queen to
check with your rook on d1
that would have been a very nice check
but now with the rooks
actually closed in on h1 maybe it's this
rook is just simply as you say not so
effective so we did see in fact nepo
recapturing with the h rook and again
just a full stop in the position and i'm
just kind of
curious why that is i mean to my mind i
see obviously the the most obvious types
of moves include d5 default that's
always a tempo of course i understand
i'm chasing the bishop to h8 capturing
on e4
also rather sedate placid queen c7 going
for a3 and queen c3 these ideas are the
ones that are going through my mind um
but with uh with a little bit of a
prayer the knight f5 doesn't just make
it exactly exactly exactly but that's
how you have to play this movie right
whether i include king h8 also to to as
you say avoid those checkmates and they
are they they definitely exist
one of the things that i find attractive
about this position for black
is
yeah e4 takes d5 great it wins a pawn
always wonderful but then when the
knight does get to do the d6 square it's
just a beautiful night
right yeah it's like a really good
looking knight so just to put that put
something on the board king h8
take the pawn put the knight on d6
and well
that just takes care of that
again on a good day i am eyeballing
ideas of queen c7 and knight b5 and
white has to
what white sacrificed upon to
pry open the g file but he's not
exploiting it not yet at least right and
that's why why i don't like the move e
takes d5 as much yes sir nicely said and
done but after king to h8
what if i go knight to d3
i'm sorry oh sorry so you played king to
h8 yes
what if i go knight to d3
okay can i
and i'm trying to stop you exactly from
what you just did putting the knight on
d6 uh-huh
well in fact you're just hitting the e5
pawn right away if i take on e4 right
what is a great idea right and this
these are the type of uh questions that
we will need to answer how is this end
game right well queen takes d2 sure i'll
take with the rook then the bishop is
coming to d4 tonight coming to f5 how is
this how dangerous is this
i would be concerned now that maybe i'd
actually put my king in in harm's way
by putting it on this diagonal i mean
it's still i mean this
it is an extra pawn for black at the
moment but but knight to season 66 once
a piece this is what
worries me about the position is that
your pieces are actually extremely bad
so i think you have to be very concrete
with this position maybe knight to d6
and
responding knight to c6 with knight to
c4 in that end game the end game that we
just looked at right now not this one
because right now i think i take only
five right okay
sorry so even at the end like take on e5
we take only exchange the queens and
then you go knight to d6 i say not
knight to g7 and try to go for knight c4
but even now what did you get at knight
c6
right knight c6 knight c4 i take on
[Laughter]
then the position is very uncomfortable
already okay so that
is we
uh understand
the pause at least
well the pause was before bishop takes
f1
he spent 30 minutes on bishop place f1
but he's paused even afterwards right i
mean he it
which and another 10 minutes after that
this is why we feel as
experienced players that already is
uncomfortable because bishop takes f1
you have to take with the rook on h on h
there is no other move right and then
you go into another thing right after a
forced movement that's where things feel
like they're not flowing
yeah i mean you have the situation where
your opponent has sacrificed
upon you know after a good thing and
then you took it
and then your opponent goes into a deep
think again well like no i mean you took
you you took the pawn that was
sacrificed you had something in mind he
spent a long time
capturing on f1 as you say christian
then there was the recapture and we're
having an equally long and i was
thinking so king to h8 okay
because if this type of sacrifices work
then i feel alireza might be in some
serious trouble so knight to d3 right
what if you just defend that pawn with
the move that you you were also
mentioning queen to c7 right right what
if i take on e5 now
take an e5 e5 yes can i hear that right
[Music]
bishop d4
followed by knight f5 and and how much
compensation
do i have scary scary it's gary whatever
it is it is scary but go ahead uh as
they say execute uh so let's go knight
to f5 let's continue okay
now i do understand that this is uh
queen h6 is coming as well yeah that was
why it was kind of like
prepping for rook to g6 so rook g8 i
mean do your worst you if you win your
piece back on f6
and now it comes the question i can also
go something like e5 right and ask you
what you're going to where are you going
to place your knight okay i jump it
doesn't look that scary e6
e6 you're going to play f6 right
actually right i've got a lot of pieces
over by my king now i mean i don't feel
like you do like am i getting made it
i'm not even sure
where the breakthrough is no where the
breakthrough well there is a tempo
fortunately for me
but yeah i i
don't see the knockout blow i don't
quite see it it does look scary but
not so clear to me that that's winning
and that is the question that both
players will have to answer right right
because knight to d3 you have to contend
with the fact that queen to c7 is just
normal reply and then if knight takes e5
doesn't work then you kind of gave me a
tempo yep
yeah well definitely a super double
edged position i really want to keep our
eyes on that we kind of lost a little
bit the track of what was going on
between icar me between richard and
hikaru let's let's see where uh the
players reached this ending
and we were saying old school would have
said great advantage to white
uh modern school says no no no no the
defensive resources are simply excellent
for black that
the double pawns on the queen side will
actually have their say one day
uh in the meanwhile
what's going on here it almost feels
like black's better
right just a second well i
so so the start i realized was knight a5
rook b8
and then i'm
forced to face the music over here
and on a king c6 c5 b6 i slowly unwind
black's pieces especially his king
seem much more active
dare i say no problems nope
one thing i don't want to do i don't
want to give up the open d5
no then i feel like i'm definitely on
the back foot yeah and i'm not a happy
camper on the other hand black doesn't
have a current thread right
other than continuing his activity i
mean well rook to d1 is a big part
yeah no well i'm just saying the
original position that you don't need to
defend the pawn that i have actually as
black i have like three moves i'm just
dying to play i'm dying to play b7 b6
king e6
and a7 a5 i'd love to expand on the
queen side slowly but but methodically
yeah and to keep my pieces as active as
possible by the way this construction
with the pawn on g4 and the knight on g5
really makes this e4 pawn vulnerable it
artificially isolates it because there's
nice yeah there's no good way to defeat
it with another pawn right i like that
yeah and guys that's one question
because we do have some breaking news
you know the game between dingley ren
and fabiano fabiano just sacrificed the
pawn after a very long thing 16 minutes
on this decision alone rook to c8 was
the move that he played and we're
actually headed towards a very similar
position to what you guys discussed the
same setup for a black rook takes c8 is
a real possibility queen takes b6 and
now we get this uh structure with the
move a4 and the queen coming to c2
potentially putting some pressure on the
pawn on f2 after the move knight knight
jumps to e4 but what if i just simply go
b3 now it's not exactly the same it's
not exactly the same exactly and this is
immediately i didn't let you play b3 at
all in that construction exactly and
right now how do you uh defend first of
all rook 28 would make a lot of sense
but the problem is i can also just
simply take and you cannot take back
with the roof because of queen to b8
that's a checkmate if you do lose a
tempo right now and make a loof for your
king i'm going to go a5 and save my pawn
right that's not possible i think on b3
right so you take on b3 and then i take
with the knight and how is this position
i i get it you put the knight on e4 but
what if i just
go push the pawn
it does feel that this is very close
very close
it is advantageous but yet very far away
from it because
if you don't make something immediately
then i push the pawn and then queen to
b7 is coming a6
i mean what is your counter chance well
exactly you're pressing on f2 but if
white as you say gets in those a5 moves
yup i mean it's an extra pawn exactly
you have to start calculating end games
after queen to c4 but
go into c4 sure i take take now you have
content with f3 ideas knight to c5 or
knight to a5
it does seem like white is one move away
from stabilizing and just enjoying for
the rest of the game an extra pawn
nice okay and by the way we're going
straight into this variation thing was
like okay show me the compensation where
is it i'm gonna pick up the pawn show me
the compensation
uh let's make some of our duda fans
happy
uh but before we do that yeah
there we go we've been waiting for this
moment i didn't want to spill the beans
were you were you batman or were you
zorro of course
shame on me
oh my god oh my god
what's this
what
[Laughter]
the last airbender um
it's a it's a serious it's an animation
isn't that a fireball and and you you
brought a lot of fireball that's the
thing that they actually have for you in
the costume in the costume i was
actually in my 20s uh like early 20s but
it was the only time i've like
straightened my i think that was like
four years ago five years ago the
photo's actually from an earlier one
yeah yeah yeah wait so you re-use the
costumes
you know like my birthday
[Laughter]
we just share your cake hopefully it's
uh cheesecake or carrot cake what did
you choose oh i hope it's cheesecake
to make our duda fans happy let's just
jump in because when we left it we had
this nagging doubts
that you know teamwork just has given
his opponent something something with
the with the advance on the queen side
c3b4
and teamwork took a very direct approach
he said okay let's trade some pieces
i'll play 97.
okay said dude i'll double up your pawns
accept it
in the meantime while the this bishop on
b5 is under attack what are you going to
do well i'll trade that
okay
now black is saying i am going to castle
long and i'm going to get in f7 pardon
me f6 f5 what are you going to do about
that well
i'll try to stop you from playing f5
seduta
rook g8
king h1 there are some ideas here that
queen h3 might have been disturbing so
that was the reason for king h1
castles would take off that bishop now
obviously we could get in like
two quick tempe in a row this would
actually be you know a hook
that we could sink our teeth into and
try to open up the queen side but in the
meantime
other things are happening over here
so due to played queen to f3 and then
timor played the most direct most
challenging
f6 f5
and in the infamous words of grandmaster
larry evans what you got here
i assume that if white wants to prove
any kind of advantage you have to take
the pawn well pretty much you put your
knight on h for some for some kind of
reason how are you going to take it with
the knight or with the pawn
probably thinking with the knight i
think is to take back and just go rook
g5 at the end and i think in both cases
i'm playing with
g5 right right but i think the other one
maybe you can get away with f6 and in
this one
right
um
so if you take with the pawn i play rook
g5 you play f6 i don't see another move
because i'm not even going to consider
hg4
[Laughter]
good for you
that is a king you're playing you know
like that's uh that's a really really
dangerous but that force is the same
position basically exactly yeah you
don't really see a way to keep mine i
can try queen h3 but but but
queen h3 knight takes h4
you have to take with the queen but
still here i go queen f5 you're not
really you're not really i'm happy yeah
by the way maybe i can start with rook
g8 you can get that star
yeah i don't feel like white's better
i'm i'm afraid that there might even be
some
like trouble yeah i i just wanted to
show uh people a pattern i once felt i
think everybody has has fallen for this
pattern once in their lives
and it's the old uh
getting mated on the the night now you
can see that this is a sarah one trap
and oops
suddenly uh you're made it down the inch
pile um
i'll be i'll be gosh darn uh it sure
feels like f6 f5 but this is so that's
the issues
games he gets worse out of the opening
he gets clobbered on the clock and then
he comes back what is the clock with
like very precise moves and this is
exactly what we're seeing from timor
right now and it does seem like perhaps
it just equalized
f5 forces this trade-off knight takes a
five and if you don't want to be worse
after he takes f5 root g5 and have to
contend with all those mating threats
maybe you just have to take with the
queen exchange the queen uh queens and
call it a day yeah perhaps this is what
he's supposed to do and he saves another
very difficult position it seems like or
at least he's on his way to saving it
and um just to just to continue the
thought how does he save the day
and we play a four
i see
right they assume no
ah thank you that should work as well
maybe even rook to e1 taking on f4 and
rook to e1 maybe that even that works
i'm a rook to e8 sorry i'm getting a lot
of compensation so not taking on f5 but
this seems to be working no just just
yeah just take one why am i looking for
compensation yeah i think on f5 right
that doesn't work for white i'm just
trying to i'm just trying to there's a
lot of uh strat scraggly looking pawns
on the board d3 as you mentioned is
under fire f7 is under fire
um rook takes f7 rook takes d3 g4 rook
takes c3
and
i feel like no no you're trying to i'm
trying to go king g2 and h4 but uh over
playing the hand well very good for
timor and our apologies if we've been a
little bit harsh
on his opening play it looks like he
solved this problem he certainly feels
that again i just want to turn to the
game of uh dingleran versus bobby again
this is such a
huge matchup i
we started our show and we kind of said
that yeah this is such a tough
tournament you can lose one game yes
but you can't lose two it's been done
before but it was very yeah it was very
very very rare ding has already lost one
game
so he definitely doesn't cannot lose
this game he can't lose it to such a
cute rival now on the other hand floppy
with the black pieces
he's sitting there saying okay i'm tied
for first
a victory over ding or draw with ding
these are really two very very very nice
results
and he sacrificed a pawn for what we
think is
counter play yes uh it's how do you rank
how do you rate the
the odds of this position
i mean i saw unfortunately uh
behind you behind christian well behind
the engine
when he was showing us the lines and it
was giving something like plus one which
is a lot more than i was thinking i was
i was thinking half a one half of one if
not right or maybe a third of one maybe
a third i mean black is so active i like
white i like white but don't trust this
engine too much all right also i mean
look at it from like a practical
language
my practical expectation is that black
holes this without any problems okay and
well without problems that's a stretch
in mind and that's my prediction and why
because
christian made a very uh obvious move he
said the pawn on a4
a4 actually kills the majority
so if i can play the move b3 and
activate my majority
i'm all i'm i'm with you there the
problem will be can you win with your
rook stuck on f1
no one day i i'm going to have to solve
the f2 issue yeah and that's going to be
my question but he's not going to get
started that's the thing is not going to
be stuck there because once i get the
pawn to a5 and it's protected by the
queen on b4 you don't have a clear way
to attack it then i'm going to go knight
to c5
and eliminate the knight we on on e4
which i would assume you're going to go
to yes
so let's just push the pawn for the
moment like i put my queen on okay just
i guess you you try to improve your
position as well let's go a5
and i put the queen on like a2 or b2 i'm
not really sure and now i go knight to
c5
i'll put it on b2
well if you put it on b2 he's still
going to go queen b6 right maybe i go
even a6 at this point i thought you were
going to do you were mentioning this
earlier i get it
but how about i go for a promotion
already i i'm greedy
on a7 and you put the queen on v8 and
life is good huh let's try
for promotion he's making a valid point
is making a very very valid point uh
alejandro
oh you probably have to swing to a2 but
then i go queen to b7 and then there's
going to be some sort of a dance once
again
knight to d6 queen to c6 and who knows
where we're going to stand after that
but it still feels like this knight will
one day land on c five yeah
not easy not easy yeah uh tom uh also uh
also known as varusia nakobian uh it
says uh knight b1 isn't completely
uh untoward either i mean you put your
pawn on a4 you want to put your knight
on e4 i could play
knight b1 to three in a go so what about
queen to be eight right now
i mean i have rook to c1 at the end so
you take take now you don't actually
have to defend them because you go to c1
this
a dream this is that's a dream right
yeah because then i will uh marching
come on over and then i'll tickle bad
news bad news so queen to b8 is not
working if that doesn't work by the way
queen to b4 was played which i assume
after queen c2 would just be a
transposition it's a transposition and i
don't see another move that's not
queen c2 exactly so it's pretty much the
same
except
it is very much the same if you play
queen c2 and i then follow it up with b3
but uh again
under the influence of uh
but now right
again
knight to e4
knight to c3 and i take yeah how is that
endgame let's have a quick quick take
i'm not so sure no you're going to
repeat it of course
you still have to make a loop yeah sir
so rook to b3
uh you're one move away
[Music]
so yeah you're saying that i have to uh
i have to respect the background
checkmate
and we're just simply in a five versus
five
dead drawing okay
got it got it all right
so
we still expect b3 after that we also
expect queensland i really don't see
that many moves here
no no and i just don't like any of those
variations where you get you go queen b8
and move up the the c file all right
keeping our eye on that one and then
again let's see what has happened with
our youngster the youngster thought for
a very very long time down to 47 minutes
you actually have half the amount of
time that nepal does wow and thought
forever play the move a through an
important inclusion in this position in
some ways
the move isn't obvious because after the
move b3 which i assume is the move for
white
uh
you do take control as white of the
square c4 which could be relevant in a
lot of these 96 variations on the other
hand like in chess happens very often
when you gain the control of one square
you lose the control over the other the
fact that c3 is weakened can be
exploited in more than one line for
example just very quickly if you play
the move queen c7 here i'm not saying
it's a good yeah sure just to put the
example that you could take on d5 yeah
and i can start looking at variations of
directly taking with the knight and they
might not work you never know but you
start looking at them right quintet
there you go queen c3 i don't know if i
want to throw in v8 and yeah here you
have knight d3 and it's still defense
but the idea is that there will be
variations in which you have to watch
out for this
no question about it
from my point of view when i see the
move a2
a4 a3 it's all it's always like who's
delivering
where with the mostest like who's
getting their fastest right
now
if i am required to play b3 then the
move a3 is an automatic but the question
is
do i have to play a3 like in the worst
case i can imagine that your pawn is
going to capture on b2 and you're going
to go queen a5 so let me just throw
something out there well let me just
throw something out there i'll play
knight b3 you take all right and now
i've got a free hand to whoops
might take some i think c4 is a big
issue that's not a big free hand okay so
we're gonna go here okay
uh with the idea that
knight f5 and queen g2
all right and if i go knight d6 here and
i say i'm going to get there first
uh we shake hands after queen chief hack
check hi it's jesus christ
good morning good morning good morning
happy birthday thank you very much
and we're going to give you two more
presents
in 96 yeah um
yeah yeah it's compelling right
i am a little scared of 96 knight c4 i
probably should throw in some kind of
defensive measure first so we'll start
with bishop h6 instead of capturing i
wonder if it changes very much i i can't
take on b2 you do have queen g5 but it
does not mate that is not me but i i my
intention
was to
honor the move a a3 b2 with knight b3
and maybe you have to go king each aid
then
okay so we've got
well the position just blowed up again
really completely uh on us and
uh we're struggling for understanding
christian uh
uh help us uh a3 does seem to be a good
move uh right but as good as it can get
at this point you're already much worse
it seems like with the black pieces a3
b3
just simple like that queen to c7 follow
it up with uh it takes d5 you cannot
take on d5 right now so that's not
uh that's out of the question right now
so what what do you do how do you play
this position the most natural way for
me is to go rook to d8
the problem is rook to the after knight
to f5 you're in some sort of trouble you
always have to lose this tempo with the
move king to h8 but then i just simply
take take and we get in these type of
positions in which that's a nasty pin
it's a nasty pin um
am i opponent no i'm not a pawn up yet
but it does feel like i have the more
prospects for an attack as well as for a
better structure later on imagine an
endgame
if you lose this pawn on b4 this one
drops on a3 as well that's going to be
bad news for your whole structure on the
king side so
the situation looks quite dire i have to
say for uh for the young man and
another thing is to our question right
because we did think well start with
bishop h6 we don't really so you want to
start with
that's what we were analyzing yeah yeah
and how would it go right this one
doesn't seem to be as compelling because
this is already apparently an advantage
for black wow the
exchange that's good yeah yeah i'm
giving you the exchange my king side
once the
exchange is being taken is going to be
completely secured
um with the bishop on f8 i'm controlling
the g7 square with two pieces so this
knight is great don't take that work
right like you're not taking the roof
yeah i just don't know what to do right
because knight f5 i always would drive a
knight of course such an issue yeah
that's a problem yeah showstopper
so
you look at these positions and we know
the pattern of allowing the pawn on b to
acting as a shield
for the white king but actually it's not
because it weakens this very important
a3 and c3 squares
and the way my knights are positioned
right now they're primed to get to that
c3 square and this is going to come with
devastating consequences so you look at
the position you start looking at all
these variations and then you understand
that
the other side of the coin allowing this
weakness on b2 and all these ideas with
queen to
c7 followed by queen to c3
it's uh the better evil let's say than
just allowing black to take on b2 uh i
think this is what and by the way as i
was speaking he just played b3 this is
on the board i i like b3 the more i
analyze the position with you guys it's
one of those moves that the more you see
the position yeah the more you
understand it what is the purpose of
both sides attackers to get to the
opponent's king
and i feel that it's much harder for
black to do so in the structures with
the pawn on b3 than in with this pawn
shield on b2 and the reason that i say
that is the positioning of the knights
that if the knight gets to c3 in a
position where you have a phone on b2
it's devastating it's devastating with
the quantum b3 the current structure in
the game i hide my king on a1 and you
might win an exchange but you don't kill
me you don't kill me and that's very
important whereas i'm going to try to
kill you on on on the king side i like
the move b3 uh
very much i think it's a very logical
approach to this position
i didn't realize that the engine was
giving such a big advantage to nepal
already me me either
i'm a little shocked uh it christian
said a3 was a good move right so that
kind of compels you to thinking oh
black's in there
guys guys it's not that clear
it's not that clear like the engine in
one move it gives you uh decides to
advantage the other one he understands
next movie he understands uh that is not
that bad so for example right now queen
to c7 it's only like plus zero seven if
you let it think for another five
minutes maybe it's going to drop maybe
it's going to increase so let's not
trust fully what the engine is saying
right now it still remains a very
complicated and complex position
nevertheless as we get closer to the
time situation the time control the
second time control one hour and 25
minutes against 45 minutes we should
definitely keep an eye on their time
spanish because ali reza in this complex
battle if he gets down on time against a
player a fast player probably one of the
fastest players on the planet yon ne
pomnyashi well yan and we've seen what
happened to ding when he was down on
time jan was putting tremendous pressure
tremendous practical pressure maybe not
finding the most precise moves
nevertheless asking the most difficult
questions when you look at the time
situation as well so this is what i'm
seeing this is the trend that i'm seeing
right now
something major has to happen for ali
reza to make yun think for a very long
time right now and i think uh the other
flip of the coin is not looking as
bright for the young frenchman i just
want to echo the
very sentiments i was saying about the
dinglaryn fabiano game
jan wins this game
he jumps to plus two he knocks a key
rival right out it gives him a big fat
zero his first loss
and
maybe doubles his own chances
of uh
winning
winning the events right because huge
game for young let's be realistic at
this point already with an hour and some
uh being thought fabiano's not winning
today no we think that he'll hold he
might well what if he loses but what if
he loses right because he is playing in
a tourist whole game what if he loses
and then gets to two fabiano's stuck at
two although the rest of stockholm want
to happen suddenly nepal at three
exactly that'll be huge i'm back and we
have a social media question let's take
a look join the fray here on our
conversation on social media we're on
twitch we're on youtube we are on
twitter at st louis chess club and from
sean mccully mccoy what do you think of
the candidates adopting the american cup
format of double elimination knockout
wow
okay uh i would just
my knee jerk was i love the american
american cup
it was so fun it
it's really really real it was really
wonderful entertainment i think it's the
best chess show
that you can get for the format that we
we could present
for the candidates though or the
candidates where you're playing for the
world championship
for the pinnacle of a player's career
like when you think of a great player
like boris gelfin
and you say boris
what was your pinnacle of your career
you said well i was playing for the
world championship match
and well how did you do that for us well
i won the candidates
if he had won the candidates from an
american cup style format
um
it might have a feeling of
lucky uh
a roulette
type of a situation right i'm saying i
loved
the the the event
as a format
maybe it's not what you need for the
world championship and to remind those
viewers that did not follow the american
couple it was a double elimination
tournament in which
if you went through the winners bracket
you kept playing classical chess but if
you dropped to the elimination or losers
bracket as it's called commonly on other
esports
you were actually changed time controls
you went into rapid
and all throughout you were playing tie
breaks to determine who moves forward
whether it was in classical over you
were in elimination in rapid there were
always tie breaks they went all the way
down to ten plus five and then you got
to armageddon and truly armageddons are
fun they're exciting they're awesome but
do you really want to determine the
candidate to the world championship
match in armageddon right that that i am
not so sure about actually i am you
don't you don't you really don't i i
just feel like you know
this one
you know it's a marathon
it's the hardest chester you're seeing
the kind of efforts that the players are
putting in
um
the the america's cup was just a lot of
fun uh uh
it could condense fun
and adapt it from online gaming right
yeah it depends on how much of a purist
you are right then it does feel like for
the world cycle world championship cycle
you need to stay at least a bit of a
furious um the american cup was in did
fun but i don't want to determine who
the candidate is from two time controls
so
if we're talking about mini matches sure
let's do mini matches and let's drop to
the elimination bracket but keep it the
same time control nevertheless
logistically that doesn't really work uh
it's very difficult to run a tournament
like that i like the american cup with
the rapid and the armageddons but we did
have fabiano caruana just winning
against jeffrey strong and knocking him
out but when jeffrey all he had to do
was finish his last move and he would
have been a completely crushing position
right getting uh the second time control
and the increment and winning that match
actually so anything could have happened
that was kind of a gamble quite a flip
coin that was uh at least that moment
and we had a couple more uh in that
particular event i just feel like
we need to keep the prestige going for
the world championship cycle so let's
keep it as this or if you want to do the
mini match keep it on the same time
control
agreed wholeheartedly uh not to flog the
horse but uh for me i always a big shout
out to our friends at norway chess
i love that competition where you play
round robin but in case of a draw you
play in armageddon to get an extra half
a point by the same token hey why not
decide the the
the candidates with an armageddon on
every draw now for us that might be
really really exciting but for the
players it might feel like they've
really
brought down the prestige
of the event by making that format
change
all right entertaining for us but
maybe not for the players you had a
comment that you wanted to
to take us alejandro please let's take a
look at chess uh i wanted to have you
ask your question about the game between
dingler and faber caron
digler and did play the movie three
securely yes fabiano is thinking
currently i don't think that the move
takes on b3 can really be replaced
uh with anything so i think a takes b3
is coming on the board yeah you cannot
take with the queen you take with the
knight
exactly so we're going to be taking with
the knight on b3 yep i would assume that
that hops to e4 the moment you can yep i
really think f3 is a terrible move
because it allows knight c3 and you are
really suffering there
wow when you play a move like f3 you
really have to be aware of the
consequence of what you're doing you're
you're leaving behind a real
weakness
so i we looked at a4 but i was wondering
how do you evaluate the move knight c5
in this position immediately you just go
immediately knight c5 you say that's an
important knight on e4 it truly is let
me just take it away while i can so i
don't allow the move rook see it first
okay so let's take the the uh the knight
and i think with the queen aha so you're
going to go into the straight rook
ending that was my question how would
you feel
about this rocking game as black because
i do have a rook behind a pawn
and an extra one yeah but i'm thinking
that if my king
gets quickly to c6 then i'll just oops
excuse me if my king gets quickly to c6
and then i quickly play rook to eight
uh i'll win one of the pawns back i mean
it's a it's a race you wouldn't be
worried
i calculated but yeah i don't think i'd
be worried i mean intuitively i would
think yeah oh i got this right i'm
saying so perhaps something that fabiano
is considering at this point is
calculating out this and just in case
that it is losing
and by the way we saw such a remarkable
piece of calculation from hikaru
nakamura and his ending and
of of round three i want to say so
it wouldn't surprise me whatsoever
that fabi is calculating precisely
these types of um
endings although
again uh knight c5 is not
required no no by any means right and
the move that
that christian
was laying on the board a4a5
um it's quite the challenge as well
again we'll keep our eye on this i
wanted to go back because ikaru's game
is
full of vim and vigor here what's going
on uh
strange things have happened okay let's
try to break this down for us when we
left this position this was the knight
g5 and the one move we did not want to
play was rook e2 when we thought that
with the move rook d8 it was quite clear
to our eyes that black had the advantage
so
richie said well guess what i've got a
real nice way of uh
capturing your queen side i'll play
knight to
a5 if you touch your b-bond i got knight
takes e6
don't
even think about taking my e pawn oops i
got you
in a pin
so
what did hikaru do did her car play rook
v8 do you think haru do
something else to you to threaten the
ipo no of course not he played h4 it's
like what okay
so both players are really upping the
ante with these moves now from black's
point of view if black could actually
play the move h3 that really hobbles uh
white's king sight somewhat dramatically
now it's clear
or pretty obvious i should say that
after knight takes b7
rook b8
black is going to recapture this pawn on
b2
and thanks nye
thanks now
to these pawns being on g4 and
creating loft
might not be
as easy as before so
uh
uh richard did not capture the pawn on
b67 rather he played the rather crafty
mover of d3
now from richard's point of view richard
is ready to capture this pawn and meet
the move rook b8 with rook b3
so what on earth was fat was
ikaru going to do he can't defend the
pawn with rook v8 because rook b3 knight
takes e4 still verboten
c5
what a remarkable move what's the idea
behind that move well if knight takes b7
rook to b8 only put it on the board
it's not like uh
i can't do
this and oops that move c5 c4 is a very
very unpleasant tickle and again the the
uh
so keep going yes sir oh how how does
the line go so let's say it would be
four so i assume i'm going to go c5
okay
okay
yeah knight d6 you're going to be
meeting up with 6 38 you're gonna be a
little unhappy about life in general i
do have check and knight e3
yeah but i i think by this point
yeah oh my god no no no black pieces are
the ones
active and it it's this is by the way
one of those really funny moments
where
i forgot the the the opponent's name of
tigran petrossian
uh was one of those you know really
really difficult names and really hard
ones to to remember but i do remember
uh
tigran playing a move like c3
in a moment like this
what was the point
uh
i don't think it necessarily
works too much in the in this particular
case
because i just simply take knight takes
e4 knight takes c3 was uh
let's see an idea ah
okay but uh i think right now white is
playing for equality
bingo that's what i think this is what
it boils down to yeah i think knight 6b7
starts inviting complications that i
have no business part of
but if you don't play knight takes b7
then your um demonstration if you will
on the queen side
is why did you go knight to c4 to a5
i felt it was in some ways a tempo
because c5 does need to be played and
it's not like you're threatening b6
every time right because b6 knight c6
still picks up a7
depending on where my rook is and stuff
like that for example right now the rook
can swing to a3 at the end of that
version h3 was played guys i i actually
like that move a lot i was looking at
this move because h3 a creates loft
and b if you take on h3 i oh wait if you
take an h3 i cannot go f4 nevermind
because now because i think only four
yeah play d4 and then f5 is coming
so he's taking on h3 already f4 and if i
take on e4 rookie 3 i do pin your knight
but because my point is already
on f4 instead of an f2 after you defend
your knight uh well you're actually
loving your knife you're your best move
therefore have three uh but how about
you play how do we feel about
okay
my question was answered um knight takes
b7 i was going to ask not taking on h3
but he did take on h3
yeah
hgh on the board yes
yeah my king is breathing a sight of
relief almost it feels kind of yeah like
boy that pawn on g4 was kind of a juicy
one okay well let's just continue
uh play here for just a moment yeah i
think i think v6 is very logical now
that uh i have the feeling after b6
knight t6 king e6
i don't want to take one a7 it's so far
away from the rest of the game but maybe
i have a spoiler uh
perspective for just a second takes push
right
now if you push i give you a check
you move your king let's say here and i
drop
in okay i go through its two
okay
so i give you a hakasito i don't have
king d3 because of rook d2
i'm gonna
be eating a lot of puns
i don't know uh king d3
rook check can't see if only move
uh
that is a knight
yeah it's true it is a night isn't it
right there's a lot of fun it's not that
many ponds only two wait a minute you're
king hold on your king is gonna be on
the queen side okay your
knight is so i'm thinking of a move like
rook b4 check and f4 and i'm trying to
get you to play rook takes f4
so that i'll have the past f-pad even
then my knight gets back on time right
is it that fast oh my gosh uh
this look help me out here
am i bargaining for king b3 okay am i
barking up a completely uh it's okay
don't go to b5 right we understand that
no okay
what don't do what don't go king devices
right before it's made oh well yeah
that's a pretty one i mean like for a6
or whatever
it's not that pretty
if a6 is made as well as rook b4 then
it's just ugly plain ugly now f4
unfortunately i think i'm going to stop
myself and say rookie one is a move but
here i was thinking like
how fast is this it's pretty fast for
white actually knight c4 and you go
knight e3 this knight is really good
it's very hard for uh blackjack to do
anything and by the way you can improve
your own when you get 35 i go knight g4
yeah
you can improve your position uh by
playing rook to b4 first
and
kicking the king all the way to a3
but you like that doesn't help you much
yeah the thing is you do end up losing a
knight right and i was thinking rook to
b4 just to try to make work this idea
king to a3 and now b5 right
well
or like f4 take on e4 and then b5 to
stop the knight from going to c4 but i
have another score now that my king is
on a3 that is uh b3
dude how many pounds have i got here
not enough
not enough no no wait i
what just a second what no way no your
king is way over on a3 but i'm not
exchanging the roofs yesterday i'll go
rook i don't know if you if you go super
greedy and you take on on e4
are you really drawing this because of
the weakness on h3 like taking b7 like
super super greedy
wow
i'm catching that
you're
knight d3 king f5 you're within no no
this cannot work there's there's no way
no no okay uh it it crossed my mind
right and we do have by the way b7 b6
which is a much more natural natural
realistic move
uh but as we try to
decipher what's going on we invite you
to join
uh our panel and uh
open it up with a question for
discussion alejandro let's take a look
at what we have from the internet from
jacob
in that spanish end game does the trade
of knights hurt or help white's winning
chances ah that's an excellent question
i would say
in general
it helps
winning white's winning chances because
black's knight is in slightly more
powerful than than white's knight ends
up being in this position the more
pieces you trade the better it is for
white
yeah
because the structure because in this
particular endgame the knight on g5 ends
up attacking more targets
than the knight on 95. if you can see
the position on the board right now
um after the move b6 knight c6 check
yep uh we've got tags uh b6 knight c6
check yes we can put the position on the
board yeah this knight is kind of
trapped i mean you'll the knight is
about to fulfill its last useful long
function which is to take on a7 and if
it doesn't take on a7 the night it's not
very happy
right it's not a very happy night yeah
and it's like uh one of those
it's time to bail with the check and
hope uh you can get out with a perpetual
but i don't think you do actually but
the the answer to the question was it
it's favorable for white to have the
knights off the board yes and you
thought that was the case because the
knight on g5 is actually better better
yeah okay so how do we feel about it
because by the way this is the position
we currently have on the board right now
how do we feel about this position who
is putting more pressure on their
opponent and i took d8 king to e5 i
don't see that going anywhere for white
exactly i just wanted to say that i
personally would find it easier to play
black yes because i'm thinking that the
knight on g5 is a very good very active
piece though king on e6 is more active
than its counterpart
the rook on d3 is better than the rook
on h8 but the rook on h8 hasn't even
moved
it's ready to go to g8 russia whether
the recon d3 will have uh more prospects
than the rook on h8 right now but they
take on a7 rook to a8 yeah but if i can
ever get a somehow get a situation where
the rook on h8 finds a very active
square
then black is going to be the one for
choice and by the way e4 guys is a very
big nibble at the moment
but the question was more like this
if you could grab both knights just take
them off the board right now that's why
would you do it
instantly
imagine no knights i go f4 i'm playing
for a win already yeah yeah that's what
i feel as well guys we're gonna spend
some time on this one but the other one
is catching fire the game between ianna
pomnyashi and ali reza because you
remember at this point after b3 one hour
and 25 minutes 47 minutes for ali reza
right and i was saying that look the
position does look easier to play at
least for the next few moves for white
you just take on d5 anyway it's black
who has to find the plan to improve his
pieces right now and this is what ali
reza spent his time on 10 minutes on the
move king to h8 down to last 37 minutes
he takes d5 instantaneously played by
yanna pomnyashi from 125 to 124. knight
to d6 another six seven minutes on this
one and by the way this seems to be just
a big mistake allowing the capture on
the pawn on b4 which
he spent three minutes on it one hour
and 20 minutes still for yon
down to his last 27 minutes for ali reza
with 30 moves to go in this wild
position
his chances are not looking good and by
the way the engine is saying that
black is completely busted yes
it's really bad for black not surprising
at all yeah
why is that why did he give up his phone
you you you invite me to take up your
pawns sure i'll take them i mean where's
your compensation i understand you're
kicking the queen away maybe rook to b8
i don't probably want to take on a3
because the knight to b5 is coming on
the board but for example after rook to
ba i drop back the queen if you do go
knight to b5 i go c4 i free up my king
and then i it doesn't feel like i have
any sort of problems you still have this
big weapon on a3 true keeping me hostage
on the on the key on the queen side but
other than that what else do you have i
mean you're gonna use that black right
now right
um i don't i'm i'm completely at the
loss of uh words i think the max
position
is us right now because i mean
that's an important point it's a huge
part by the way i mean
i i like what you said that you maintain
the weapon on a3 ah it's nice
we can show that um
on our board yasser uh no if you take
one a three because we got there i was
like yesterday smelled one pawn he
smelled the second part
you wanted to take this one as well
i saw queen takes a3 and i would i
actually got stuck after knight b5 green
b2 but knights before actually but
knight c4 is the nice fight that wakes
up more than that right it's not even
winning for black
what
this is not winning i go queen a6 queen
a6 you take on e3 and then we just
played this position after d6 it's still
not over
black is slightly better but you do have
to find some very precise moves so not
even but it's a wild position
exactly and uh you're gonna play night i
mean you're some pawns up you start
trading pieces
but the thing the thing is
bishop h6 is humongous right queen takes
five oh yes yes no play on one goal he's
just blitzing out his moves right now
by the way once again
yeah well once again i want to say that
uh
earlier
right here is where i just said look
guys i just have to say this
nepo is thrilled and delighted this is
his that's his style
he loves this kind of chaotic and the
fact that
uh farouza began to burn his clock more
and more and more just
you know inflames
uh nepo and right now he is on a roll
brook to say it was played at the
university
not root beer i wanted to point out that
um anish giri actually did a nice recap
of some of the
some of the games that have been played
so far and i took a look at his recap
very briefly and he was mentioning that
part of prep modern in modern days
it doesn't involve so much getting an
advantage necessarily by force against
your opponent the way it used to be that
you just play the strong prep no matter
who sits in front of you and you get a
very good position chad doesn't really
work that way anymore we have so many
positions in which we realistically get
an equal position but right there's
equal and there's equal and you're
really trying to prepare against your
opponent stylistically what kind of
positions do i want to get against which
opponent and bingo yeah this one as you
you we feel
goes straight into a napa territory like
straight into the complications straight
into the mess that nepal really really
thrives in exactly and if i have to say
you get this night or against nepal
specifically
you don't play it i mean you have to
know it really well right like okay
there were a lot of positions in chess
that i really liked a lot especially
when i was white and some really
complicated nimzo indians
and i would never allow michael paul to
play them against me right i would want
to play them against john timmon i'd
want to play him against robert hoover
or to use useful all of these other
players but i don't want to give
my opponent a position that
suits him stylistically and
obviously anisha is absolutely right you
you want to guide the
the game into a play
where there is play but also where it's
uh antagonistic towards your opponent
your opponent doesn't like technical
positions or doesn't like very very
sharp positions sharp positions is what
nepo thrives on guys
yes christian first of all nepo could do
himself a lot of good today with a
victory and a potential loss by fabiano
caruana we don't know exactly what's
happening in that one but fabiano is
definitely under tremendous pressure now
with the last move
rook to c8 which was just played
nepo right now has a crushing plus six
advantage
wow
it's over the game is over if he manages
to calculate precisely all the way until
the end bishop to b6
and this is the key
you have two squares for the queen if
you go to d7 the very natural square
queen to e1 and there is no way to
defend the pawn on e5 once this pawn
drops the game is over because i'm
getting to your king
if you go e4 the game is over because
you open up
you cannot do that so
the only move is knight to g4 you're
never gonna play this i i follow it up
with h3 kick the knight away it's over
busted so once the bishop comes to b6 if
he plays it
alireza will have to play queen to e8
okay be ready to defend after a queen to
e1 with knight c7 but
now i have rook takes f6 exactly oh my
word you cannot take because i just
simply take on f6 that's very easily uh
calculable knight to b5 has to be played
right with dc it's still complicated
let's see at least
let's go you took a lot of pieces let's
go yeah yeah baby yeah sure right king
to a1 and we get this position
it's completely over positive
take take take i get the queen how many
pieces
you're not checkmating me and not even
close
this is over
right if it sees bishop to b6 this idea
i think this is the hidden idea
one drop
if he sees bishop b6 followed by queen
to b1 and it all comes down to the
consequences right you do understand
that you want to open up
this diagonal this is what you're
looking at for a very uh for like the
last five moves six moves or so now
you do understand that after bishop to
b6 not only that you attack the queen
but you're also as a consequence opening
up the e file
and then you drop back with the queen
dropping back with the queen comes
natural right because
some sort of ideas after knight to c4
and opening up these diagonal discovery
attacks are coming on the board so you
have to be aware of that dropping the
queen makes sense but if you couple it
with this idea of also opening up the e
file
the game is over the game unlock unlocks
itself and the game is over bishop to b6
finishes the game by the way i the
reason why i find myself drawn to the
move bishop b6 is not just because i
always look at the forcing moves first
but i ask myself the question is
why did you play rook c8
oh
i know you played rook c8 so you could
play queen c7 b6 on the board and attack
yeah and attack my pawn on c2
so if i play bishop b6 you don't get to
play queen c7 and that's i find myself
attracted to that move you see it kind
of instantly actually right it's a very
logical move to open the e file
he's crushing him right now this changes
everything in terms of the odds
and our number two seed is
really really really in big trouble
right
well he's grabbing this early leads he
did so last year as well right and let's
see if he nurses it because last year we
also had a crucial early round between
dingle and fabiano caruana which proved
to be crucial for the final standings of
that tournament it's very reminiscent of
what happened to vichy anand after he
lost his first match against magnus
carlsen he came back and destroyed the
next candidate sure it's true
this is what i'm seeing from nepal right
now some sort of uh surge of confidence
he's like i face the final boss
i can deal with you guys right now and
this is exactly what he's showing off
especially in this game against ali reza
he's just blitzing out his moves he
still has one hour and 16 minutes on the
clock crushing position right now almost
an hour extra compared to his opponent
this is all she wrote
alireza is done what a crushing
performance but something strange in the
alareza camp and i have to say
i don't exactly know who he is working
with
uh we have seen him with ivan chaparrino
recently right but uh we haven't had
full confirmation of his team i think
he's keeping all of his teams secret
uh
but this feels
wrong like something went wrong but not
only that but i mean
it's ali reza is the one who's chosen
the super super uh sharp double-edged uh
with the whole a4 bishop c4 c4 business
and i there's no question that he had
this position on his board
but his subsequent play
has not been
impressive uh rookie
very quickly very quickly in the
variations certainly bishop b6 and
wow by the way uh in
the candidates that i played in
uh we played uh
the it's not just the the pressure at
your own board
but oftentimes you just got to get up
and you walk around
and you look at somebody else's board
and say oh you're having problems too
right now fabi you know he's
gets up from his game with ding or he's
down
where he's down upon and he goes over to
look at jan's game and goes oh no oh god
pressure piles on because you feel that
you have to keep up with the player
that's leading precisely yeah yeah
exactly that's what it meant yeah and
how bad is bobby's position well
he hasn't played so we still don't
really know
how it is i suspect knight c5 is that's
wrong just to draw i expect that a4 is
the one that uh
will keep fabby at the board uh trying
to yeah i keep it precise i actually
took a peek and i wasn't so sure about
this and we think we think all the rest
is dead so let's let's oh for sure for a
little bit this is going to be really
important for the standings a4 and i
wanted to tickle your brain on another
uh potential rook and game yes you play
them with queen c4 we left it off pretty
vague but we might as well go down in
the variations because you don't have a
lot of moves with your knight
after the trade after and you have to
trade yeah
uh you might even have to play the move
i mean knight a5 is not the most pretty
no it's not pretty at all and i think
both c3 or rook ca look kind of
i'm going to be just fine
is it that clear that should we continue
the lines all right i'll go c3 okay i'll
i'll draw you out tell me what you're
doing
i think i can go c2
or rook v8 first i'm not really sure
c2
seriously can i get away with that
i can't believe that
what if i take rook v8
right
can that really no i can't beat
uh what what's the body count here in
the rook and look android pawn
only that's it
um
should be a draw yeah you know play king
you you you'll uh
finagle somehow to get the a you you'll
get an extra move in to to get out of
the back rank mate and then it will be
five versus four but how easy is that
because i do have e5 followed by e4 and
d5 right
like i managed to create that second
that's still keeping you at the board
i think i play f6 for the loft right
okay just a second so let's take it move
by move what do you do oh
king to e2
uh ke7 okay king d2 rook c4 sure or okay
whatever yeah
we're going to try to design game this
is
white's having some fun here that's
having a lot of fun here yeah yeah maybe
not so easy right let's go back to this
position after knight a5 perhaps there's
an easier way to do this for me i went
c3 i went f3 um
i didn't know why don't you go um
c3 what did you play with i win f3 f3
okay i wanted to play rook c1 but what
about knight to d2 now i'm not sure i
have time for because you were going to
play rook c1 i assume c1 rook a8 right
i'm always missing one move yes yes
let me explain the question
[Laughter]
that when i play rook take c3 there's a
background mate
is there a bamboo stick coming out yes
let me introduce
it's still not that easy no no no queen
c4
um
still not fully equalized and by the way
this is a
crucial moment absolutely crucial the
clock times of the players
but by the way is queen c4 the only move
no no no i was just at a question 55
minutes for being right now thinking
thinking actually for the past 20
minutes um
39 minutes for
fabiano did he play a4 i don't know he
has not played a4 at all
well that's because i think he's also
calculating this
knight c5 take take take take rook c8
and it does feel like it's a draw right
so rook to c6 perhaps or king to f8
kingf8 maybe
the computer is saying that it's not
that easy really i'm trying to
understand why i guess i'm just putting
my pawn here and then
he thinks that this position might be
complicated after it takes you seven
years i mean it's not complicated so
they're winning or it's a draw right
precisely yeah so maybe it's just me
all right maybe it's just a draw
maybe
just a second okay
who could be winning i mean e5 yeah
king
yeah okay now black has to stay at some
point i will go eight before king a3 and
then you will have to create your own
passport i just lost actually
i i won such a position as black
this yes how did you manage that i had
like a pawn on g4 and i i then i did a a
breakthrough upon breakthrough you
tricked your opponent and that's just no
it was brilliant it was like a d5
so it put black's pawn on in this
position go g5 sure
and just if yeah but don't go g4 go h4
g4 i'll go a4 and i go g4 i'll go
right and this and so i i had my
opponent kind of stuck
and then i went h h6 h5 sure and
keep staying and i got i gotta i got a
pawn breakthrough i'll keep staying and
then push yeah
uh no the other way the other way and
now you push it with g3 yeah yeah that
way
here you go each three right if you take
like this you go f3 yeah very nice it
was nice it was nice okay very
educational i have to say cruz in the
the moscow olympiad 1994.
this is important right because
we're about to take a break but if
knight c5 wins it just wins
well no no no no no it's not it's not
that easy it's not that easy knight c5
knight takes e5 queen takes c5 and we
said king to f5 we we didn't have to
play let's stop the pawn
[Music]
yeah and then get out
on c5 i love the move rook c6 that's a
masterful move so that you can actually
bring the king in front king d7 and then
to a6 and then get the king to c7 not
exchange and this is why thing lyran is
taking a 20-plus minute thing because
he's analyzing all of these subtleties
in the rook ending he's analyzing a4
let's let him think we're going to take
a short break and we'll be right back
and on the other side we will actually
have a special guest anastasia
nasty of course so we'll be right back
in a few minutes as we let alareza
suffer and we'll be right back
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championship
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys gonna see this
that's our show now go start yours at
this is
[Music]
you have kids you already know st louis
has a ton of fun stuff for families to
do like the magic house or the science
center and if you really want to be a
stellar parent come see all the new
stuff there is to discover at st louis
union station with a new mirror maze
light shows and the 20-story high st
louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent feel like a star
saint lou is always exploring
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to round four we
are already on the third hour of play
and we still have no results faber
caruana is currently defending in the
game against the england but breaking
news is that janet farmy and she has a
crushing position against alvarez who is
down to five minutes on his clock for
our remaining 15 moves of chess to do
the math and how long has left and
that's probably the least of his
problems yeah it was exactly here we
left it and this is where christian
pointed out you know guys
jan has this brilliant maneuver it
starts with the move bishop b6 and it
continues
with the move queen e1 it's it's rather
a hidden idea but it's a beautiful
conception the screen on b4 drops back
now that the bishop is no longer in its
way queen takes e5 if that ever lands on
the board forget about it game over done
and dusted and he found the maneuver and
according to our chess engines well he
didn't find the maneuver he blitzed out
i lifted it up
it was a hard one you were defined for
ali reza for us for mere mortals but for
yon and for the engine it was just a
cakewalk
walk in the park
and also breaking news in the very
crucial matchup as well in the dingler
in game uh take it over for me here uh
uh alejandro we left it at this position
and you were asking about the move queen
c4 we kind of got bogged down in the
direction of knight a5 yeah dingler in
surprised us with knight c5 why did he
do that well it seems like it's a very
forcing line uh we don't have well we do
have the move knight takes c5 there's
surely no one move
especially because the knight is so good
right yeah you have to eliminate it
that's got to go so knight takes pontex
and it really comes down to tempo
counting right uh the move rook c8
doesn't seem
to be the most accurate in my opinion
okay
let me count that out if you go rook c8
right yes i will go kind of by force
root being one or maybe go a5 a5 okay
i don't know which one i started with
hey you take rook a1 so your rook
doesn't go behind the phone and i
actually have to go back sooner push
push but no i can't go you go you go you
get there faster right right which is
why perhaps i don't want to do it this
way okay
uh here i think i go
rook b1 first okay trying to make this
work for a white but i haven't been able
to
i have to get out of back rank nate in
order to take this pawn
but you will
precisely
and i want to go c3 is how to defend
this one
well rook b5 will definitely walk into
c3
how did how was i doing this on my
variations because i was looking mainly
on rook k8 and i forgot why i discarded
rook c8 but it actually looks very
logical oh first of all if you've
refuted rook a8 let's go with wrestling
i thought it was the draw and i thought
rook c8 was the worst move
i didn't realize that you could play
with c8 and just take the phone do you
know you're known as the man with all
the answers
ruining your reputation let's go into
that variation or to see a rookie series
okay what how the take help us out there
so let's try to figure it out all right
one rook to be one now that's a bad
grade
and i step out of the back rank me and
what if i push a
five
take it
take it right i am on time okay one you
go c yeah okay one two three and
first
i've got two threads c3 as well as we're
not faster than i am that's a problem
that looks like just a draw okay so
let's try to do this differently well i
mean if rook c8 draws on the spot it's
going to be an enormous relief
for fabriano
enormous relief so hold on
i mean the way i'm thinking is you got
to get your king to see one or
so like
could i play
rook to b1
king
now if you play c3 then i'll go king
here
this is just the draw right right right
right
they want
c3 c2 then what i mean king d3 c2 right
it's just a draw
seems to be creating i'd be able to
trade my c4 uh
uh
uh
no
no no no
maybe i'm actually i could be worse
it may not be a drug i could be worse i
don't know uh
no
this looks wrong all right let's try to
figure it out okay because this is
definitely not it
is the computer that's not it i guess
rook to c8 yes help is out
i mean i don't want to use the engine i
don't want to score the part hold on
hold on hold on roxy one i take a pawn
then then i do what i get what you want
to do you want to put the king on c3 and
that's what we're going to want sorry
let's go
yeah yeah king f1 i would do it this way
because with my rook on c1 i'm tethering
you to the pawn right so if you want to
use the tempo with c you have to lose
the tempo with c through but then you're
not on time
that makes sense yeah because now you
see
d2 and then i have rook a1
c2 king d2 i get it i get it yeah yeah
yeah yeah
let's show that let's show that actually
because it's very important yeah it's
very important
c2
kd2 yeah and now i'm going to hide the
king to c1 correct that was what i was
hoping to achieve was to bring my king
quickly to c1 and get behind the a pawn
and it's it's
it might be winning it's extremely
dangerous yeah this is
the one
line definitely to be avoided but now
how do we get here once again so rook c8
rook c1 by the way
seriously
uh i think
for many many competitive chess players
the move rook c1 would not be an obvious
move at all no i mean this is an awkward
move for a lot of top players to find
and then
rook takes king
and we're here now okay if i kind of get
there right you guys do you do get to
the king to c3 and the rook to a1 setup
which i
we're not guaranteeing is winning or
anything like that i mean you could go
king f8 king e2 e7 king d2 king d6
and i get my king to c5 all the way even
that
might might be a draw
right but you're kind of
hoping with black oh you're king b4
actually never mind
you're not getting i'm not getting about
getting c5 no
no no no yeah so you're one temple too
that was why we tried c3 a time
uh a turn before
and uh king e2
let's say king f8
king oops that wasn't what we did i
think we did what did we do uh but here
cooking d3 is okay right
yeah how did we get our we we first
played uh rook c4 to attack the phone on
uh yeah
guys we're gonna have a lot of time to
uh calculate this game and take it uh
take it away keep look at it but let's
take a look at what's happening in the
game between jan and ali reza because
this might be over very very soon so i
just want to catch the final moments of
it uh after queen to d7 queen to e1
alireza dropped down to his last three
minutes play the move rook to b8
immediately followed by bishop to a5 and
now we have the position after knight to
c4 yan is still thinking one minute
and 24 seconds no increment
for ali reza for the next uh 12 moves or
so
bishop to c3 just makes a lot of sense
right yeah how do you defend against
this knight takes d5 i check
if you take i take and then the knight
is hanging so you have to start with the
move f6 but this just gives me a rook
how do you take back and i understand
you have some nice
swarming around my king but
and by the way d6 was played yeah this
expression d8 instantly replied us he
has to play instantly right
he has to play recently because he's
going to lose that fight but the
inclusion of d6 looks even
more appealing appealing for white than
that so he's now bishop
to c3 right right yeah
yeah
three now queen three six nine what is
that three what is the other thread
right i'm just feeling like i defend
this i'm just trying to get my pawn to
f6 and then hope for something hope that
you don't break through right
but i'm looking at knight d3 it's a huge
hope and i'm just saying knight d7
no i mean king song king a1 king a1 just
creates an immediate threat that this is
over yeah wow
not hard so let's d6 is pretty by the
way bishop takes d8 also works but
do you want to give up and uh give up
dark square bishop perhaps not no why
not i mean but i think and i guess f6 is
hanging yeah yeah i think with the queen
i go knight f5 it looks completely oh my
gosh domination this is over also this
is overall everything is over the thing
is black cannot create a threat no
and there's going to be a queen c3 in
the position guys it doesn't matter yeah
at that point the game is
lost we lost uh track of it some while
ago but richie versus ikaro has actually
been a very intriguing game when we left
it we left it around these parts knight
check king e6 knight takes a7 we were
saying all hikaru really needs to have a
serious advantage is to
activate his rook well guess what he did
but
the problem is the knight has taken upon
he's got ideas of f for check as well as
knight takes b6
even though black has all of his
why did i give a rook check i'm not sure
even though black has all of his pieces
very active he is a pawn down
and that means that white
is
probably doing well enough for draw i
think
yeah i don't know much more than that i
was wondering why you couldn't take on
e4 here uh why did you give a check and
not take on
e4
how first of all how would you like to
take on i was thinking with the knight
okay
you know well not with the king
obviously no but a
few things let's set this up in a few
more
ways uh
knight takes b6 and rook takes b2 and
stuff like this i kind of would like to
start
if i could with the smooth c4 and you're
kind of hoping that against f4 you do
not
lose but i think you can take c4 knight
c3 knight c3 you take on f4 ah
no but you still have now i finally
understand why
ikaru included the move rook a1 check
but even even this is not so no it's not
he wanted he didn't want to leave his
knight on free apartment is rook on
three but i still don't see how to how
to win it yeah there's no win right now
because of rook d4 king e5 group
[Laughter]
okay sorry i'm not sure actually i
understand
i actually wanted to start with c4 ikaru
started with rook check we are here i
think we're up to yeah yeah we're
playing
what the clock uh it's 29 minutes for
richard and 40 minutes for hikaru so
plenty of time for both players and how
do we evaluate this is it even is it
better black
who do you like need
not looking at the engine i mean
i feel black has enough activity
yeah i also feel that it's enough but it
should not be more than enough it's just
no mating
i mean on a good day you take on b6 i
get to go knight f4 check and king cakes
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think that this cannot be worse for
black i i even would go as far as saying
i'd rather take black in a practical
right because of the activity because of
the activity but i also think that the
chances of this
simplify somehow into a draw it's not
very high it's pretty high well well we
think three results are possible we
think the most probable result is a draw
good enough uh let's jump uh quickly
again
our apologies for our duda fans it's
just that the other three games are so
incredibly compelling in terms of the
tournament when we left it we were
accolades to
[Music]
timor he had played f5 and rook g5 in
this combination we've actually seen
something like this
and we thought black could actually be
doing
quite well
queen f4 what a decision that is
queen of four
i almost think uh that with your rooks
and the you wanna you wanna checkmate
yeah you wanna keep for you wanna keep
the pieces on the door it's a very
teamwork move well wouldn't you to like
okay
either
queen uh e6 to c6 to i mean
anything that keeps attention right yeah
i i understand that a5 is coming for bla
for white but by the way i've got king d
you know it's always funny when when i
have these type of positions and my
opponent puts a lot of energy into
opening up the queen side and then i go
king d7 yes at the end it's like what
have you got just fine the king is going
to be fine and i agree with you i think
the king on d7 is great i would have put
too much league in f4
just draws i mean it's it's a it's a
unambitious move as
very often teamwork tends to play
especially wild black especially while
black and he's just saying my the same
game is completely drawn why would i
ever be worse here
okay he might be right and he might be
right jumping to dingle
yeah he actually played rook a8 which
expects
favida was your expectation it was my
expectation that i didn't know why but
we figured out that rook c8 maybe rook
c1 is dangerous but he this one i
actually was working through the please
tell me and i couldn't figure out a way
to keep the game alive for dingler end
okay you kind of have to defend your
pawn you have to waste of doing so but
uh neither of them
that as far as i saw it really came to
an advantage okay one is of course the
most logical move
but as well as as long as rugby won
let me go with rook b1 for just a moment
all right and here i do kind of have to
bring the king in okay and now let me
tickle you with rook
here all right and c3 c3 is more or less
right and then c2 i don't know if i need
that move okay
there's a very funny line actually i can
play king e7 first right yeah so
check this line out please okay k7 c6
let's continue this board yeah
and now c2
okay
well now you could play c7 and be like
oh wait i'm very close to winning if you
go king d7 i take on c2
and then i'm going to beat two pawns up
right right but rook takes a4 finishes
the game but for the other side
because interestingly promoting to a
knight doesn't actually do anything it
doesn't do anything and if you promote
to a queen rook to a1 and the c2 pawn
covers
that's an easy trap to fall for my
goodness
and the thing is you're always getting
mated so for example after c6 c2
rook takes rook takes a4 you actually do
have to spend that tempo right yeah and
i'm going to corral this
i mean you're just like you can't d6 i
think i just got king d6 why are you
guys making yourself seven c7 rookie oh
wait a second what am i doing
first
okay
[Laughter]
now you go king d6 and i think you can
safely take this pawn in almost every
variation and the point being that if
you do try to uh penetrate via the
seventh rank with rook d2
rook c8 rook d7 king e8 and that just
forces even to give the eight
i really maybe even i don't see that
sure
this is awesome
right
we'll make a repetition right now right
away
uh nicely calculated by fabiano this
move rook to a8 very very important
because rook to c8 was quite problematic
after c1 so once again rook to b1
sorry once again you were saying that
there are two ways for ding to try to
pressure
fabi one was rook to b1 and we just saw
a consequential line of why that would
not work for ding
what was how does the other line with
rook a1 go i think you still have to
bring in the king king
you bring yours king f1
and we get to a very similar position
but this one i actually do get my king
to c5 so you'll keep me too
do i need it i want to play a5 and rook
a4 or is that just transpo
transpositional transposer i mean a5
king d7 i don't think well whoa whoa
whoa okay that's fine king c6
whoa whoa whoa
is this fine
this is just fine let's take a look this
rook looks really dangerous that's true
holy smokes
christian jump in
bail is out we we did something wrong
we
we we managed to find a way for fabi to
lose
is it losing
rook d8 you have to go rook a yeah you
have to do something because c2 is a
thread
i apologize let me go
to right yeah of course but i don't know
if it's the same
ta
i don't think it changes any i think it
changes a lot asap what
r okay
okay i take on c5
whoa
no way
but how do you enter the seventh round
that's the question
right away what do you mean king pisa
king d6
uh
oh am i losing
why am i losing this but that's not even
a question
but you don't you don't have a
penetration square
i'll get my king back oh yeah that's
that's a good point yeah check on d3
take on a6 yeah holy smokes
so just a second even though i can get
my king to e5 that's okay that's okay
you don't have anything else up or down
and
i could
keep this has to be a trial right okay
my king all the way to the king's fight
oh my god seven f6 next move no this is
yeah that seems like i saw some
some primer once that showed you know
like the offensive white king yeah
overpowering uh the
the passive black king
hi
well done uh i
it's kind of tempo by tempo but it's
like it works right
by the way this is what
happens so often in these you know
really really high level games
every variation
every variation comes down to one tempo
and it just it it's remarkable how that
uh works rook a8 on the board and
dingleran and the times if you don't
mind uh the time for dingler and curling
is 39 minutes and fabio is down to 21 at
the time a bunch of us to make but
they're kind of obvious right because
once you go down a particular path once
you choose a path at this point you
don't have a lot of choices right as
black if you have to bring in your king
well you started with rook a8 and you
can almost pre-move
king f8 and king e7 and yes yeah pretty
much yeah yeah so plenty of time for
both players and this one that's not
going to be a factor let's jump back to
the
nepo uh game just to
see one minute left yeah he switched uh
he didn't take on d8 he played bishop c3
which we thought was completely good
queen e6 boss played
sorry when we left it we just saw this
move d6 bishop d8 we were looking at
bishop takes d8 which we thought was
really strong we thought the move bishop
c3 was really starting in short we felt
that white had this game
uh
completely under control
knight to d3 knight to d5 and this is
where we currently stand that is where
we stand it still feels like most moves
should win yeah
i know it's just the question is which
is the cleanest
but we have a special guest with us uh
we have a guest from us anastasia carlos
joining us actually from athens greece
hello nathia
hello everybody it's so great to see you
i'm in greece you're right
how are you enjoying the candidates
uh of i'm enjoying my candidates almost
at the beach you know i just put this
jacket on my swimming suit but no matter
where you are you are watching the
candidates even though i'm in athens now
we have plus 35 degrees i'm very near to
the sea i cannot do anything i have to
stay here and watch the games because
they are so exciting and we have so much
action right
how are you
guys
we're not at the beach we're not in our
swimsuits so we we we have issues that
we will like to address later
uh but we we're loving
the the the games we think the players
are playing so hard
each and every round the fights
are just what we imagine
those candidates could bring us
anastasia we don't want to put you on
the spot about what are you seeing so
far from these players which player is
uh taking your attention
yeah it's really it's very difficult to
judge at the moment we still have the uh
the round number four at the moment uh
but what i can say from now that of
course i mean somehow jan shows quite uh
self confident play and um i'm really a
little bit afraid that if he wins this
candidate magnus will say i don't want
to play this match
this is i really worry at the moment so
um i don't know let's see how it goes
but at the moment uh jan looks the best
at this moment but everything can change
you know i've seen uh i've been to
almost every candidate's tournament uh
not like maurice ashley who just said
yesterday that it's his first one
actually i think it's a second one which
i'm missing since 2013 and i've seen
that sometimes
things can change so dramatically after
the middle of the tournament i remember
aranyan who played very well in london
suddenly started to play differently on
the second half of the candidates so we
have seen different examples uh okay
it looks interesting so far
well guys let's keep one of the boards
open on napo's game we do have a bunch
of moves at night
they will come very quickly right so let
us see if there's a way to have
anastasia here join us in the
conversation because network game is so
crucial for the standings and it's
moving quickly yeah and i just saw this
knight you know like land on the square
b2 and it was just like kind of uh
amusing to me that uh after
uh the move rook f4
queen e2 i i mean i'm assuming that uh
um
nepo has set up a trap he's made his
tank
i think you just take i think with the
queen
queen why am i dealing with the queen
can you think with the bishops it's
easier
it's sure enough
and
well you can't take the pawn because of
bishop and knight v2 and i just thought
that is
that is very very funny uh
i
what do you think of this move knight v2
i mean so it's an interesting move but i
really don't want to be on a live in
malireza's seat right now i mean it's
really unpleasant position to play i
think he understands that things are not
going well at this moment so he's just
trying you know to find some tricks to
still stay in the game 35 seconds now
anastasia what do you think about the
time control for uh these candidates no
increment how do you feel about that yes
how do you feel it affects their play
yes it's always like that and it's a
very unique tournament with this uh time
controller remember of course vasily
vancouver lost five games in london uh
just because of this time control when
you don't have increment it's really
different uh game right you have to take
care of your times so much and
i think it affects a little bit uh the
players and the result maybe actually
that's why yami pumice has some
advantage because we know how fast he
used to play and uh how fast he uh makes
his decisions so i don't know what do
you think would you like to play with
this time control or not
no i i think the players are used as you
just said
to the increment
and when they don't have the increment
they often
[Music]
get tasered yeah they flounder a little
bit and you can see that ali reza i mean
he's left himself literally five seconds
per move from here until time control
and he has actually how many seven or
yeah seven seven more moves 35 seconds
i remember this whole times when i
played like maybe 15 moves in 13 seconds
but you better don't go for this right
15 moves in 13 seconds yes yes one time
and put this league i just have managed
to do something like that
remind me not to challenge you in any
bullet games
how many pieces did you lose in the
process
can you imagine they even won the game
but the team our captain of the team had
heart attack of course you can imagine
yes exactly now uh unfortunately for uh
ali reza he's searching for cheapos he's
played this move knight b2
and unfortunately for
for ali reza he's playing against a guy
nepo
who loves he thrives on such moments
where he can play literally move for
move he's not going to let you think
for the next seven seconds or something
and he's just blitzing down to 17
seconds i assume the move even rook
takes h7
must win right that could win you know
what's really a cheeky move
rook goes back to f4
you were just on f4 but you played f6
thank you so much right
to block the diagonal okay you're just
having too much fun right now wow
[Laughter]
wow
natasha
final thoughts uh
who is your predicted winner right now
with round four underway
uh of course i'm rooting for fabiano
caruana because if he plays really well
i have my chance to go to madrid maybe
and follow the tournament from there so
of course i'm rooting for him so he's my
ticket to
madrid you can imagine
okay
i love hobbies
also
and also i just wanted to say uh
congratulations to alejandro who has
birthday today we have a birthday boy in
the studio so alejandro all the best for
you
very much thank you i've seen many
comments people keep sending you
messages yes
lovely you know it'll be a tough day for
my phone thank you for uh breaking away
from the beach uh as compelling as it
sounds and joining us always a pleasure
to see you well thank you so much for
joining us
and we have a couple of updates guys uh
the movie f5 was played in nepo's
position we think it's just completely
busted right yeah h7 just kills him on
this yeah
i was thinking yeah birthday boy coming
up with the goodies rook h7 busts
how bad is it christian oh it's
oh it's
it's made but it does look like okay you
have to go queen h6 after queen to h5 oh
really yeah check made it if you go king
jail f5 right i don't have to cut then
just takes f5 you don't have root to g1
is coming knight h6 is coming it's it's
over finito yeah yeah yeah that's just
me and mate yeah maybe somehow
rook h7 uh we think does it sorry i
i was being impolite maybe
but rook f4
felt like
how bad
on a point count we know white's winning
but is it but yes sir your mate is mate
i just you're in neon's shoes right now
yes now i remember this boxer vasily
lomachenko
and at some point he was beating these
guys so hard that the other guys were
like throwing the towel and they were
like no mas no mas no mas
this is what we're seeing right now and
what jan wants alireza to say no mas
just let me resign as fast as possible
and get out of here right because you
want to get that dominant psychological
edge okay
he's taken on h7 take on h7 wow
yeah he's done yeah he's done it i mean
queen to h5 it's strong it'll be over as
strong as it is obvious and i think
we're going to see a handshake oh he
played king g8
he actually played the move king g8 uh
so lost the m8 is coming
wow
let me turn on my engine i'm actually
curious by the way i made it seven
knight takes f5 on the board as
predicted still he has two more moves to
make bishops
calculate this mate right g1 king f8
queen h6 king of star of g7 it's
just
100 but you even i can do that one yeah
i mean you feeling it rook g1 king
queen h6
and look at that this is your birthday
that's pretty nice
not this isn't the epaulette mate why
this is a different setup
you know that i only learned that
checkmates had names when i was already
way beyond grandmaster i know isn't that
crazy i had no idea right somebody told
me like the anastacious mater i was like
the what yeah i was like an expert and i
thought i i knew a lot about and rook g1
it is over he has resigned others of
russia
consolidates himself as the leader of
determine he will almost definitely be
the sole leader of this event we have
almost no chance that fabiano carolina
wins that unless i don't think around
flags right uh so nepal will be going
out of round four as the clear leader of
the candidates this is the position that
he found himself in
the first uh
in the first bout in the 2020 candidates
not yet the 2021 gun right
as this is the current score larissa
falls to minus one
yandere pony actually three points out
of four what a start for the road
seriously uh my my jaw is kind of on the
table here because after four rounds we
have our number one seed and our number
two seed currently at this exact moment
both standing on minus one
i didn't see that happening not at all i
mean i really did not a lot of people
were thinking the top three players are
going to be
dingle ren and fabiano caruana right and
if you see most of the that's 60 of the
package that's going to take the
challenger the dark horse being on right
yeah which everybody thinks yeah he
could win it yeah but to see two of the
favorites on minus one
so early no way disappearing yeah i
didn't they didn't imagine
that at all but first of all let's just
say
this was an emphatic
wonderful victory for for
a position that he loves exactly
well thank you
this is what i do this is what i do for
a living let me show you how i do it
and i think that
this preparation
i mean hindsight's 2020 right i mean it
comes with this very interesting idea of
bishop c4 he must have analyzed it
bishop c4 all the way back we said that
the main line from the super sharp super
sharp long variations variation that's
right i felt that perhaps he knew move
by move on some other variation not
specifically so right here oh sorry
sorry this is the movie
so
so we have this well-known theoretical
battle with f5 and there's a whole
stream of games that now continue a4
bishop c4
important sideline yet still a sideline
such a sideline and then after this move
d5 it was f6 that really started back he
hit back and it seems like alireza was
unprepared and when you think about a
move like bishop c4 which was only
played a couple of moves ago yep
and if you're not prepared already by
the point that f6 comes it feels that
the preparation wasn't so deep it wasn't
so deep right perhaps it was deep but
not wide wide enough for the candidates
and when we talk about
width in the preparation is how many
moves are you considering right perhaps
he went very deep on what the engine
thought was the main line maybe for me
it's
a move i would resist playing myself and
that move i would resist is capturing
the problem is is that i'm really
bringing i'm helping my opponent i'm
bringing his pieces into play and let's
move bishop f1
and right here
but it's not even that guys it's not
about the width of the preparation it's
just about the fact that he didn't
understand the positions yeah that's
that's another thing
he was not familiar with where to put
the pieces the timing of a position such
as this one is also extremely important
it just doesn't feel like he had a lot
of experience and coming into the
candidates this was
the question that everybody had on their
mind does he have at only 18 years of
age turning 19 during the candidates
does he have enough experience to play
at the level come up with new ideas come
up with new openings as we're seeing
right now does he have enough experience
up to this point it doesn't seem like he
does it doesn't seem that he he is
definitely bringing the fire in the
opening she's bringing the fire against
hikaru excellent opening preparation
really went into this crazy end game
hikaru played like a monster and
defended like a machine can't really do
much against exactly
applause but in this one it does feel
that jan simply played
logical moves he played king b1 he
played rook h takes f1 i mean he didn't
do anything that special no he just
crushed his opponent with with logical
good moves alireza seemed like he didn't
know what to do a fish out of water and
sorry to interrupt you guys uh we do our
we are expecting two results quickly
very very very quickly as both richard
rapport against
icaru are
really headed towards the drama wow that
was like
a vacuum yeah already
actually already drawn uh this as you
can see there's only knights on the
board we left it off here after the move
rookie
rookie 196. and we very quickly just
vacuumed the ball rookie three takes
takes takes on e4 takes on f6 takes on
e3 knight d5 take the queen side as well
we eliminated that queen side we
eliminated this pawn
nice yeah professional professional draw
so draw a greed already between richard
rapport and hikaru nakamura meanwhile
the john shishtav do the game against
it's also
b-lining straight into a draw both sides
with two pawns and a rook
as we can get that game and game up we
left it off in what would seem like a
very equal double rook end game they've
also found a way to vacuum the board
here
very good and also we
think
no this is the dingle ring game right
yeah between rokayo and rook b1 dingle
ran already thinking for quite a while
but this is the only game the one of
dingle around that is alive at all
uh every other game is just either dead
or finished uh the rajabo game is going
to finish anytime soon so dingley random
versus fabiano karana will be the only
uh result that we still have pending
and everything to play for or do we just
really think
we expect a draw within the next half
hour i would say
50 minutes half half hour 15 minutes i
just wanted to say one last comment on
no there'll be many many more comments
on this game yeah
of the ali riza game but one of the
things that really stood out for me is
uh youth the youths they're basically
unsound you know like they don't have
enough maturity in their play and one of
the reasons why they don't have enough
maturity in their play is because they
play too quickly
youths just
always ahead on the clock
ali reza he played slowly and poorly
that was a very very bad combination
normally you don't see that normally
they play quickly and poorly or
something of that nature here he played
the move knight uh pardon me
terrible
rook c8 was no good um and then after
that he just never he well he can't
recover now he's oh he's already
poisoned by force very quickly right it
felt that he didn't put any resistance
that even after getting the position
that he might have well prepared on the
board he just got blown off the board i
mean this position is so
it's not even difficult to understand
that this position is dead lost right
exactly
king's very weak white's king is very
safe pawn on e5 vulnerable wants this
diagonal opens you allow me to play
queen takes e5 and bishop d4 we can just
sign the score sheet so that's no that's
done and dusted uh the game between duda
and rajabov as expected has finished in
a draw okay very good nothing to say
then it doesn't
which leaves us
with one game remaining and one very
very happy
nepo oh absolutely if every other game
is drawn
nepo is the one that surges through the
rankings he will be the only one on plus
two only fabiano will be a half a point
behind would be a half a point behind if
uh this finishes in a draw i think he
would be even happier if uh lingleran
wins
uh i was gonna say that uh
if
fabi does manage to hold the game as we
came on the show we're talking about the
odds of winning the percentage of
winning
uh
again if abby manages to draw this game
i suspect
that the models are going to say it's 50
in favor
of two players yes bobby or nepo exactly
right becoming challenger
you can kind of see it right making an
exit will be uh alireza
minus one outside of just the numbers it
does feel that
i mean it it really does feel assuming
thing loren and favi draw let's just
make that assumption we're not
guaranteeing it no but we do think it's
a heavy favorite the dingler in a fight
we draw so let's assume that they draw
bobby would be half a point away from
nepo correct uh but some of the
favorites look at them perruja would be
tied for last with dingler and a half
away
already
a point and a half away and from the
other players uh richard richard
and rapport yeah uh sorry richard
only players at 50 yes only hikaru has
impressed me
and i will tell you why because hikaru
has played three blacks
[Music]
that's a good point yeah the only white
he played he won right and then he lost
the fabian happens with black with black
and the other two uh games with the
black pieces had no trouble whatsoever
today he had no trouble whatsoever
against richard upward understood he's
battling perfectly
and meanwhile dingleran is actually on
three whites out of four no way really
yes because he started oh my gosh
with a loss with white yeah against
nepal yeah then he drew his next game
right
that didn't convert against richard a
winning position and now he's wide
against uh favi right now as well so he
started with three out of four whites
which you're the opposite of what hikaru
has done you might think it's not a big
deal but when it comes down to the
tournament later and
you see the positions like well i have
to win with black winning on demand with
white is tough enough yeah with black
it's
almost an impossibility
wow
christian with a special segment as
we're waiting for dinglan to make his
move in the only game remaining
christian take it away
well it is a blast from the past guys
there we go we do have some nice
graphics as well it seems like and i
want to discuss
about
this game between dingley wren and
fabiano caruana it seems like we have
some problems there we go
this was from the candidates in 2020 the
same color formation dingle around with
the white pieces fabiano with the black
pieces and it was a completely different
game than what we're seeing today
it started off in this love dxc4 a4
bishop to f5 knight to uh e5 e6 f3
preparing uh the advanced in the center
bishop to b4 knight to c4 and this was
all preparation by both players castle
king to f2 getting off this pin and
getting ready to play the move e4 and
now came the big surprise a shocker of a
move by fabiano caruana e5 this was the
novelty that pretty much killed this
variation at that point came up with
this idea and dingley run started
thinking he spent a lot of time on his
next few moves he wanted he was under
tremendous pressure by the way this is
the idea it's tied to the fact that i
can target your queen and now the knight
on e5 if you do take on c2 then i'm just
simply going to take on d4 recapture on
e5 with a better prospect for the black
pieces queen to d2 c5 immediately
putting a lot of pressure white is still
a pawn up nevertheless with the king
very very weak on f2 and all the pieces
swarming around it is going to be a
difficult defense but dingly wren was up
to the task and we got to this position
knight to g6 was a big mistake by
fabiano he was out of his preparation
right now out of his depth
rook to c8 would have been the better
move and after knight to e3 we get a
completely wild position something along
the lines of knight to h5 here and
knight to e6 imagine this type of
explosive content coming on the board he
played the move knight to g6 and we got
into this position which ding by the way
managed to uh stabilize it incredibly
well and went on to win a smooth game
after that in fact the king was quite
safe the queen came back to the defense
everything is compact for white right
now
and these pawns are just going to be
decisive later on i let you take that
pawn on a4 that's fine you have the
prospect of getting a passport on the a
file but these two central pawns are
going to kill the game and this is
exactly what happened
ding went on after losing two games at
the beginning of the tournament went on
to play spoilers role for fabiano's
tournament
won this one and unfortunately for
fabiano it wasn't enough after that to
recover and go on to win the candidates
this is the blast from the past that
happened in the past candidates but
right now the position we currently have
on the board seems to be going straight
into the draw that we discussed
thank you chris i'd absolutely remember
that game because it's so it was so it
was so crucial
first of all
secondly bobby's preparation was simply
so outstanding we were sitting there
going wow this is great e5
c2 rookie eight look at him go
and he brought this
um one of the most amazing novelties
that i've seen in the candidates
and he lost the game as the game
progressed it was like being slowly
slowly stabilized
then he kept his center he returned upon
activated his king
and in each step we go oh my gosh
he's getting better oh my gosh
you know fabi's not going to win this
game we just you know he started so
strongly yeah and it was really one of
the games that really took the wind out
of uh fabby sales
and his campaign
literally was
ended
[Music]
it wasn't fully ended he did bounce back
coming into the 2021 portion of that
candidates with a win against mvl uh
which was again another outstanding
piece of preparation yeah he really gave
himself a chance unfortunately i think
he really sealed his deal losing to
anish correct with this opens and sawing
that he didn't
really got blown away in that game uh
we're going straight into the variation
that we were looking at earlier guys
everything so far knight takes c5d takes
rook a rook b1 and instantly we have
king f8 rook before we have a bunch of
moves c3 rook c4 king e7 king f1 now you
are kind of threatening king e2 uh if
you cross the king to the d-file and i
go king e2 you don't have this rook d8
ideas exactly so you will get your king
to catch the pawn so you have to
jettison the pawn right away c2 rook
takes c2 rook takes a4 this is the
current position on the board uh we
looked at this we actually looked at the
move c6 even uh we decided that rook 8
was just a draw and exactly we still
think that and we do uh and if the king
gets to c6 even if i don't win your pawn
on c5 immediately we know it's wrong
then the rook will simply be tethered to
the pawn and you're not going to win
a king a rook and pod end game with a
very passive rook i think the bigger
question is yes white have any way to
actually prolong this game or
is just going to fizzle out into a four
versus four
i don't quite see it i have to say so
what if i try to go from behind
so rook to b2 i'll give up the c5
king on e7 right
rook to b2 right to b2
okay going the rugby seven is yeah let's
go okay so now rook to b8
rook to where is he where is my clever
where are you going from behind
if you do go to h8 i don't like you you
actually end up stalled yeah
all right so i will wait for you to go
with the king to d7 i'm going to go king
to it rook to a7 king to it
yeah you're going to wait for me fair
there no no rook to b2 is fine
yeah
which i understand okay now king tweet
excellent and i go do you wanna
i'll
be five i'll force you to right and then
he's kind of waiting for us to go king
d7 and something something and now maybe
rook
to b8 why how does that this looks
uncomfortable i i i don't know i didn't
like rook c7 i like d7 right away
immediately it feels more natural yeah
you're keeping your rook uh
when you
when you get to play king c6 so now i go
group to b
or now you go rook b8 now i go rook to b
okay so show us now i can give you a
check right
maybe you don't want that no it's okay
i'm kind of living with it okay king d3
are you sure
well i
kind of feel like i've got this pawn
under control
as soon as you go c6 i drop back with my
king and in the meanwhile i want to go
munch myself
c6
well i'll go back we don't have anything
i can take on f2 okay
c7 okay i don't know what chess works
here yeah
that's just a draw right
now
right
black is winning
nobody's winning anything
okay so you gave me a check on a2 at
some point and i went king d3 or i went
king d3 by myself what if i just like so
i give you you go king c6 i go look to
ce8 you go king b5 and now i go king to
f3
king the f3 fair fairfare okay that's
the same though we're okay too
well he he wants flavor
yeah yes i mean he
i
you know he's going christian he has
occasionally you know the blind
the blind chicken finds the corn
uh
i'll wait for you outside
what was not after the show this is by
the way that that was uh the insult that
uh victor loved to toss around you know
like whenever i played a good move
the blind the hand finds the the cord
all right i have a question if
we want to be more professional about
this okay i'm not sure about allowing
everything that we just allowed you
played into this position right now if i
give you what you wanted and i play rook
c7 i i assume here you're going to
taking okay
you take my pawn right
oh
i can live with the lawsuit i can listen
i can lose my edge phone right i don't
think i well
i don't think that this should be that
big of a problem right but i don't
really want to do it like this because
that makes you look passive right you
can go k7 wait for me and then go g6 and
the c5 pawn
good point yeah thank you christian that
phone will die at some point i guess
i guess so even though it's two pawns up
at the moment it's temporary because i
will simply
capture this one on the next four versus
three but i guess this is the best thing
can get at this point well the fact that
he he could get this far is already
pretty good yeah some
something good uh but let's take a pause
and invite our audience to join the
stream absolutely we are on all kinds of
social media join the conversation on
twitch uh on youtube and we are we we
are looking for some of the best
questions to put up here the birthday
boy from g master
g4
okay which one is better playing someone
on their birthday or your own
oh definitely definitely against someone
on their birthday right yeah i mean come
on i kind of felt like a little weird
myself i'm playing on my own birthday
but but let's not comfortable let's be
very real it's best to play them the day
after
yeah yeah yeah yeah let them celebrate
let them celebrate
good point i mean
yeah
[Laughter]
you know we had the
i
was raised on chess informatives
right so it was this uh
twice a year
uh
book with 600 700 of the absolutely best
grandmaster games
carefully combed selected by the editors
of the chess informants
annotated by the players
and they had the these keys
uh to because it was a languageless
annotation
so for example a square
was used to say forced move and things
like that and we thought that we could
improve the informative code by adding
some further symbols
so one of the symbols uh that i wanted
to include was a pillow
you know you see a little pillow and
what does that mean pillow dream
position
this is what you're aiming for you've
achieved your dream position so you've
put a little pillow
but then what you've just said
is
a party hat a party hat
so this is the way you could annotate
the game
the player hadn't recovered from the
party from the night before nobody had
it yeah this was very good
okay
thank you for uh that birthday boy but
uh one more let's go let's go all right
let's see what we got uh from youtube
user jake lacey hi jake candida do you
think would create the most exciting
world championship match
take away give it a shot ah man at the
beginning of the tournament i would have
thought uh dingleran okay because i've
always felt kind of like
breaking through he was breaking through
and i kind of felt like aronian that at
some point we want to see this
breakthrough match you know it's a
different side of the world they're
coming up with a completely
new team new face in a match format
right we've already seen uh fabi we saw
uh
two russians play against magnus exactly
we haven't seen anybody from the asian
continent to really put that pressure on
magnus we saw vichy right but uh that
was a long time ago already i mean we're
talking about eight years ago that that
match happened i want to see a new fresh
face from the asian continent to come in
and challenge magnus and i'll echo that
point uh
very much so because here in st louis
that we have the sinkfield cup with two
players magnus and the dingler in tita
first and in an extremely well played
tiebreak i think it was the first tie
break that magnus had lost in 10 years
dinglerin won and we thought whoa and
that was already a few years ago we
thought wow dinglerin is going to become
a great competitor then he kind of faded
the last candidates was not his best so
yes coming into this event i thought
like yourself that ding lingering would
make a great
uh but i thought fabi would also yeah be
a great match-up i mean i i'd love to
see more experience that's what i'm
saying yeah he's going to come in with
he's a much better plus player much
better rapid player everything about
fabi's game in my opinion he's improved
since 2018 except it's raining
but what about you chris
his rating hasn't been there but his
play has been excellent great
i hear you guys i i hear fabi i hear
ding i myself want to see a rematch
between fabiano and magnus i feel like
we've been robbed a little bit with the
rabbit situation it finished so fast i
was in london and it finished us boom
boom boom three yo let's go home uh i
wanna feel that again i wanna feel that
match again and see what's going to
happen um a few years later but
one match up that i think will uh ruffle
the most feathers around the chess world
is the one between magnus carson and
hikaru nakamura
that would be an interesting one look in
a match situation i know
hikaru has a pretty bad score against
magnus carlsen right now i think he's a
12 to two or maybe 12 to one or
something like that it's pretty bad but
at the same time you know you're going
to have a lot of eyes tuning in into
that matchup hikaru is probably going to
be able to build a pretty serious team
going into that one he's going to have a
lot of time to prepare and we haven't
seen these two players face each other
in a match situation i think that would
be quite an interesting the only thing i
would be worried about hikaru winning
the candidates is that we're going to
see the match between hikaru and whoever
finishes second
no
no way no chance if hikaru wins magnus
plays for sure
can you imagine the buzz
around that match i mean
you would get a hundred thousand viewers
every single day easily i just don't
know if easily i mean it is a it is a 13
or 14 to one score i mean that is pretty
lopsided
if magnus says i don't want to play you
i don't think the chess world would be
like oh he's scared
[Laughter]
you don't know you don't know hikaru
fans come on right they would definitely
be like magnus you're scared and also
then having put that out there i have to
put the other side out there too after
the second half performance in dubai a
lot of chess fans are not looking
necessarily forward to a rematch between
magnus and aneppo and nepo sitting there
saying hey wait a minute you know like
guys i mean include me in the
conversation yeah and i think that again
it comes down to experience right i
think that was prep it was there but it
didn't suit him and i think that team
nepo will take so many lessons of what
went wrong in dubai mentally
physically i mean spiritually to a
certain level
preparation preparation wise and they'll
they'll really give magnus a run for his
money button again like the other
players
it was such a convincing crush
yeah uh
well what can i say it was his first
time under the anvil that is to say
uh nepo had never played in the world
championship match before he didn't have
that world championship match experience
and he
and he lost us exhausting marathon game
let's just
take a look at the lifetime matchup
between magnus and ani
and we've been told that it's a 14-1
with 26 draws
14 1 is one of those that's pretty
serious pretty serious yeah
you know
we've always uh congratulated magnus by
keeping something close to a 40 or 50
rating point gap between him and his
number two rival maybe
uh at his peak uh fabi narrowed that gap
to maybe 20 points or something actually
when they played the world championship
match they were two points away two
points away even better
but hikaru has contributed 70 ranking
points
to magnus's favor
here let me give you five more okay i'll
let you very much
i mean truly right i mean 14 to one main
donation
did he skip a donation somewhere you
know
like
but uh we're gonna keep a very careful
eye on what we think is gonna be a draw
in our final game we'll take a break and
we'll see on the other side
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody it is the fourth
round of the 2022 candidates and we
already have three results on our boards
and look at that yanafon yeti is
separating himself from the fact he's
the only one on three points a beautiful
plus two for him roberto carrada has a
chance to catch him against lingard but
scratch that zero chance there because
daleran is certainly not losing today's
game he might win but that also seems
unlikely we currently have a four versus
three end game in which a draw is i
would say 98 favorite in which case
bobby would be trailing uh our new soul
leader by half a point that would be it
and digloran would join alareza uh
furuja anthony with rajawat there with a
minus one at the bottom with a minus one
score so that's where we stand in the
event
uh let's take a look at where we stand
in the current position as we do have a
few moves but the essence of the
position hasn't really changed
um so
at the highest levels
four versus three
95
drawn uh
three versus two even higher
two versus one and then finally one
versus none uh highest of all the last
move rook d7 does present present
pavi with a very nice opportunity in my
view of playing the move a g6 g5 he's
taking it because you want to just
reduce these bonds off the board and any
pawn trade is actually in the favor of
the defender and he's by g5 what's
easier than a four versus three three
versus two yes and so two simplifies
one and one is very easy yeah keep
simplifying the pawns trade the pawns
don't trade the rooks definitely don't
trade their rogues so the movie g5
actually was played in the game yeah it
makes tactical sense at the moment
because if you would like to keep the h
pawn alive but unfortunately the move h5
simply separates the pawn from the rest
of the field and after the hg4 you will
eventually pick up uh h5 yeah
it's a way of self isolation yeah while
we were just on our lunch break and we
were discussing the position we weren't
discussing this particular four versus
three the question that we might have
asked ourselves and we didn't really
answer it is have we seen in the
candidates a player lose
in the candidates obviously we've seen
players lose 4 versus 3 in other events
whether it be the olympiad or inner
zonals or continentals or whatever
um i just couldn't recall a case but uh
helping the candidates
candidates one side wins up four versus
three correct
yes you did yes yes yes um
levon aronian
beats hikaru nakamura in the candidates
of 2016 when hikaru
reaches for his king and touches the
king was that the candidates of the
world cup no that was the candidates
that was the candidate that was the case
the car reaches for his king he touches
the case and realizes
that
it loses that's the one that loses but
and
and lavoie immediately reminds him yeah
that's true right right uh higher things
forever realizes he's lost make some
moves and loses uh he would have drawn
the game if no touch movie i actually
realized that he was losing right but it
does exist and um okay so that's the
case
it's such a rarity
that i i
didn't
somehow i
connected that particular game with the
world cup not with the candidates yeah
that was definitely the candidates that
just pulled it up it was it was it was a
three versus two it wasn't a four versus
three but
well right now is three versus two yeah
well right now
that's right and now it's two versus one
yeah
now it's
h takes king takes rook d4 with the
moves that were played
so uh again trade pawns not rooks uh for
the
for the defender this case uh the move
rook a3 is a nice move
uh
looks very good to establish our pawn on
e4 check especially when white cannot
move his e pawn so dingler in tried g4
and there we go
there we go
we're even in there
one now and uh
zero's root
everywhere i mean this is the easiest
version for black at the moment
there's no actual plan i think that we
saw this end game
but slightly worse right if you put the
part on e3 to g3 yes it's still
technically a draw we saw that game
furuja with the black pieces defended
bob against raj above in the first round
right uh but with the quantum e3 it is
ah
a lot easier right because there is no
past form to worry about so the only way
that white can make progress is to
create a passport by trading phones
right he has to go rook over e4 f4 and
then at some moment he plays for the f5
and that's that's the trade that
that the final trade that you want
i think there's only one risk you want
to make sure
that somehow
you never get a situation where your
pawn is on e5
and the king is cut off
from the
from the sixth rank the king is cut off
so you don't get to defend the upon with
the kick yeah just keep your pawn on e6
i think it's a proper technique even if
the computer says e5 is just as good as
anything else i i just keep the quality
six it's much easier on your own life
exactly exactly so once again uh
the sequence of moves that i would like
to avoid
as black even though the computer says
oh it's perfectly all right this is the
this is a step towards the world it's
not being perfectly all right no exactly
so we do have the move uh e5 and then
king f6 and at this point after the move
f4
at some point you do start wondering
when do you
preserve energy right because i mean
torturing favi for two hours here it's
not it's not going to really lead
anywhere
and
two hours that you spend over the board
on the tournament that's 14 rounds long
yeah
yeah yeah i mean you got to pace
yourself too and keep in mind like
sometimes you just got to tip your hat
say a good game uh christian uh jump
right in and your thoughts about this
ending well this time game is going to
be a draw in a matter of minutes uh but
i was actually uh looking through some
games of ding i remember this game
against honest chook from the 2012
olympiad and uh he actually won three
versus two in this one in a very very
important clash i think this gave the
chinese team the victory in that
particular match against the united
states rook to a4 and ding is with the
white pieces it's a bit more of a
difficult position
the pawns are not connected to each
other we have f and h nevertheless it's
still a very easy technical draw uh at
least it's supposed to be rook to d3
rook to a4 up to d4 and i think this is
where he made his mistake rookie d6
rotates h4 and now
perhaps he uh forgot about this number
f4 yeah because of course if you take
with the g pawn then rook to uh well
actually you don't have rook to f4 but
rook to a4 and this pawn is not going
anywhere if you take with the rook then
i take on g5 he perhaps forgot about
this uh move f4 rook takes f6 is going
to come i'm going to have to connect
passer and that's just going to be
winning for white so accidents happen
guys accidents happen but
not in this one this one is definitely
going towards
a draw i would assume ding is just going
to have to deal with the checks right
now roon g1 rook f1 you're going to put
the king on the second rank and at some
point you're going to have to go f5
this is it all she wrote uh whenever you
go rook to b6 i can always just go to
the seventh prank not allow any sort of
f5 pins on the sixth rank none of that
this is an easy draw
very nice
and let's just take a look at what is
coming up tomorrow alejandro do the
honors another huge round we have fabi
caruana with the white pieces against
richard rapport and again if you try to
see where you're to get your chances
richard has been seen a little iffy on
openings shaky at times yes and five you
know that he's an expert meanwhile raj
jabba will playing with the white pieces
against the rent uh win by either one of
these players kind of falls up to 50 and
back into the tournament a wounded
perugia and a wounded ferugia will be
playing with white hungry against john
shisht of duda and meanwhile a huge
matchup for sure hikaru nakamura 150
percent will be playing against
nepomiaccio on plus two with the white
pieces and kara got once
with the white pieces out of four games
and he won it and he won it so it's a
big one hakkar with the second white of
the tournament despite being round five
and you know that he's hungry and he has
a great chance he wins he ties with
first place drags him right that reels
him right back off that perch and he
goes right into where he wants to be a
type of first right exactly that would
guarantee him at least a type of person
so here's our current standings with the
one game remaining again we are
expecting a draw bobby will go into the
uh
go into tomorrow uh trailing by a half a
point but that match-up between karu at
two and nepal at three for tomorrow
that will be a barn burner i wonder how
these two match up actually in their
individual results scores head to head
because i think and hikaru and nepo
because i have a feeling
that those guys have as many decisive
games as drawing games i think i think
they both swing for the fences
i'll just look up that statistic for you
one of the things that i'm really
impressed uh for those of you don't know
i mean alejandros has some really really
remarkable computer skills and so when
he says he's going to look so oh here it
comes look at this
cupcakes
i've been waiting
wow
go go ahead tell us what we got here
i got that part
tyler with the info the inside yes of
course
second i mean no no no no no no no
go ahead
i'll take that right i'll take one of
these i assume what what is that what is
it red velvet looks like red velvet okay
anything chocolate is good chocolate
it's very good to your good health and
success sir uh thank you guys happy
birthday to alejandro everyone i
appreciate it
do i get one or no no no no no all right
i'm getting one as well thank you tyler
appreciate it let's pick this one oh
pretty good
right
red
baby local shop
and then they're from the cupcakery
oh this is getting okay we are getting a
camera
uh that hikaru has defeated
nepo three times three to two with five
draws um oh it's exactly what i thought
no i i thought that they'd have more
decisive games than draw but it's
actually five five right uh the games
are from uh
quite some time ago they haven't played
in literally years uh
the last time they played against each
other in classical chess was all the way
back in 2017 no five years ago really it
seems like a little strange no that's
crazy let's see if i got that right that
cannot be possibly correct right five
years ago no no i i apologize that they
played since i don't know why i said
that
uh the last time i see that they played
a decisive game
in a classical match
the skilling open is an online event
right
that was a rapid event
that was a rapid event that was a rapid
event that was a rapid event
my god is all the way down to 2019 sing
field cup really
was that the last time they played
classical chess well then you had the
pandemic of course i guess that makes
sense right it gave us this massive
interruption of over the board play
everything went online
and uh oh
the bishop ending that oh yeah i feel
familiar
game yeah yeah netball won the last time
that they played i remember this game
actually
quite the game as well
um
in any case uh tomorrow's matchup is
just you that's huge
wow
and uh we'll definitely be here to call
all the action on that one as the
excitement will only get more and once
again could i see that pairing i got it
in front of me but i just want to share
it with everybody that
bobby should he draw this game we'll
have the white pieces against richard
rapport in a game where fabi will be
saying look i need to catch up
with um
nepo so he'll certainly come with guns
blazing and for farouja duda
uh that's gonna be a well it's
i'm maybe i'm being purpley but that's a
kind of a make or break game right now
for both of those players they need a
win i do like our pairings have they've
already assumed that fabian thing
they gave it
tom has to make these executive calls
and he doesn't want to rely upon his you
know no talent
just grandmaster staff
[Music]
that's how we roll that's very nice
that's very nice but uh by the way again
these uh games today i think from for
myself the three games that were just so
huge
and i that that young victory
doubles his chances literally of winning
the event ah it's just a huge victory i
guess such a competitor oh what are the
number two
nothing more to say the way that he did
it is a confidence boost right we know
that nepo specifically is a very tricky
player he loves
taking charge being able to play well
and win his games and when he loses he
just
goes away
yeah there's almost kind of a tilt
and now nepo is back to number five in
the world with this victory uh something
that he lost
through the match
yes and he seems to be searching i mean
you can't ever count nepo a lot of
people have talked about pre-tournament
odds and favorites and everybody says
look yeah there's favorites but you
can't count nepo out no in any of these
tournaments and he's proving why yeah
well i remember speaking with peter
svidler here in st louis and uh peter
saying that he's such a streaky player
you know you just don't know what you're
going to get if he wins the
tournament with a a nice score yeah that
can happen and he can equally
have as many decisive
games
meaning wins and losses as draws he's
that streaky player but when he's on a
roll like you saw today you saw nepo at
his very best and
it's pretty dark
it's pretty scary whenever plays well he
really plays well the the issue is when
he plays badly right but if he can get
his psyche in the tournament and i
really focus on on
playing the best that he can every game
right giving everything that he can
every game and that's the difficulty of
the tournament that you don't slip
and that was a big point of uh
contention
uh in the 2020 candidates because we cut
it off in the middle
just after he lost a game against mvo
and allowed him to catch him up
uh in the first place so a lot of people
were saying like oh he got a break
because he was going down swinging in uh
the second half of the candidates if the
tournament would have continued it
didn't he was able to recover after that
loss he was able to basically start a
new another tournament and this is
exactly what we're seeing from nepal at
the beginning of the tournament
especially when he's in shape he's a
very dangerous player yeah one of the
things that really stood out in the
whole kasparov karpov
rivalry that spanned so many years is
when when karpov was world champion
from let's say the 75 to 85 period when
he had a bad result
he was third or second
that was a bad result i mean he was so
often times first in his career gary
kasparov
when he played like gary kasparov he's
plus
you know five six seven
and he would win the tournament walking
away when gary had a bad result he was
second or third
you know nepo he has a bad result he
could be in the second half of the uh of
the field if you if you follow what i'm
saying oh totally yeah magnus has a bad
result he's second
he's
and then you don't want to play in the
next tournament with him because he's
going to get he's going to take it out
on you yeah so yeah there's something
about these world champions where a bad
result really is like
this is the thing about everybody else
would be a great reality yeah to a
certain degree that's also true for fabi
where if he has a bad tournament he
finishes on minus one and yeah he maybe
he is in the lower half of the
tournament but not that bad right and
most of the tournaments he is finishing
second or third right in his
participations uh we have a few couple
moves please and that was the whole
point the e6 pawn is so good yeah uh
black is just basically waiting waiting
waiting for this pawn to
make its way to the fi square thank you
very much that helps
us
now the only question is
you know do you want to be you know
tricky or more precise by giving a rook
check or do you find it necessary i
personally don't think it's even
necessary i think g1 is just a lot
easier just the easier that's the
easiest yeah because if you take on f5
you think with the king then i have to
worry about rook e7
and i guess it's still kind of an easy
draw but i don't see an easy way into a
philadelphia yeah which is what i would
do whereas rook g1 i see you i force you
to take with the pawn on um on f5
or to misplace your rook well you don't
misplace the rook yeah rook f1 king e5
e takes f5 and either you take with the
pawn which i love
or you play rook f6 and misplace your
rook because like with king e7 or takes
f5 and this one is much much much easier
right
here can you trade
so that's even easier so he has played
yeah i agree rook g1 is the easiest in
that case and we're going right into
that variation rook f1 play king e5
played there's only one
possible move anybody thinks of here
yeah
it would
show a discernable lack of talent
takes he says
[Laughter]
checkers is still a challenging game
oh nice nice okay we get feeling a
little loopy here as we rounding down
uh the play in round four
if this game does end in the draw as we
expect ding lyrin's chances keep
slipping and slipping away this is his
third white is the third one out of four
games which is the the main thing right
for which he has gone minus one for
which he is a minus one performance to
show of it is exactly what you don't
want to see with white with white they
they want to re they went and straight
into the repetition they're going rook
g7 reggie said uh ricky simon rick v6 so
we can call this a draw uh i believe
it's a draw
officially yeah yeah
yeah
not a great result for the chinese
players still plenty of chess to be
played and we have seen uh players win
with black in this tournament yeah
before it's not like it doesn't happen
but a bit of a nightmare start there for
uh
i would think a terrible terrible start
maybe maybe not as bad as his previous
candidate starts which is we know he
started with a minus two but uh minus
two but he recovered with a victory
against fabi so he was actually only a
minus one at this point
okay so it's kind of uh
the same and with this game this draw in
the
record books we have three draws today
and one victory of course a huge victory
for yaniponnyachi as he defeats alireza
firuja and is now sitting pretty three
points out of four and a plus two score
on only four games two with white and
two with black he is sitting very very
happily there at the top of the
leaderboard he is being chased by
fabiano carrano who is only half a point
behind and that fact that must be hungry
which sets it up for a great matchup
tomorrow between batman hikaru nakamura
on two points he's won a game lost the
game he's on 50 and he will be playing
nepo tomorrow for the tournament lead
wow
great stuff and uh again our
congratulations to nepo i
it's early days but that might well be
the game of the tournament at least so
far i mean it's just it was so
impressive to my eyes it certainly adds
pressure to his opponents a lot of
people say well i mean yeah you're not
i'm not going to do that to alireza
necessarily right right where am i going
to get my points and that was already
played some of the top competitors you
already played favi you already played
exactly
so let's see what happens in the next
few rounds exactly christian so final
thoughts about today's round i have to
say i'm just mightily impressed with the
way napo carries himself uh not only the
quality of the game by the way he
carried himself he just blitzed out the
sequence of uh the move that just put
alireza away so i'm definitely sensing a
boost in his confidence after november
after losing in that match against
magnus carlsen he wants to get back in
that's it he wants to challenge magnus
carlsen once again and he's off to a
great start and of course fabiano
caruana patiently defending i really
like what i'm saying from uh fabi fresh
opening preparation that knight to a5
and after that after falling into let's
say more of a difficult situation he
patiently defended found that important
very precise move rook to a8 and managed
to make a draw this uh two contenders
are definitely head to head and they're
in great shape but tomorrow we're going
to have some amazing matchups and we'll
be here to call all the action
thank you christian i just want to say
forget about these candidates it's all
about the birthday boy
congratulations once again alejandro
that was really really nice come on in
caru you can do it
and my prediction is not looking good
thank you everybody and thank you for
joining well me on my birthday and the
candidates in their tournament it's been
a fun event so far really do not have
disappointing candidates whatsoever it's
been fun to call it we'll be back
tomorrow with round five from madrid
we'll be here in the studio in st louis
join us tomorrow same time same place
good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited